Das Rasenfunk – Tribünengespräch.
Ein Trainer ist nicht ein Idiot. Ein Trainer sieht, was passiert im Platz. Wir haben beide gemeinsam den Fußballlehrer gemacht, im gleichen Jahr. Trotzdem war Julian zu dem Zeitpunkt schon Cheftrainer und mitten im Abstiegskampf mit der TSG. Das darf man nicht vergessen. So viel Zeit hat er dann auch nicht zur Verfügung, um sich auf die gewissen Prüfungen vorzubereiten. Ansonsten wäre er sicherlich auch lehrgangsbester geworden.
Giovanni Trappattoni, Domenico Tedesco und Julian Nagelsmann, was haben sie alle drei gemein? Sie sind Fußballtrainer und damit Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu diesem Tribünengespräch im Rasenfunk. Mein Name ist Max Hackebost, ich bin der Gehnetzer bei Twitter und freue mich, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, dass ihr das hier jetzt hört. Denn wir wollen sprechen über Trainer, über Fußballtrainer. Wie wird man Fußballtrainer? Wie wichtig sind Fußballtrainer? Was hat der DFB dazu beigetragen, dass wir jetzt ein paar neue Gesichter, wir haben davon einige im Intro auch schon gehört, in der Bundesliga sieht? Also ein monothematisches Tribünengespräch, das uns hoffentlich viel, viel, viele Erkenntnisse bringen wird. Und warum ich mir da jetzt schon so sicher bin, das liegt sicherlich nicht an meiner Anwesenheit, sondern an der Anwesenheit meiner zwei Gesprächsgäste. Zum einen Björn Müller, der selbst Fußball spielte, unter anderem bei der zweiten von Uerdingen, Bochum und bei Wattenscheid 09, war dann später Nachwuchskoordinator und beim Hamburger Fußballverband tätig und ab 2013 beim DFB für den Fußballlehrer zuständig für die Ausbildung mitverantwortlich. Danach Co-Trainer von Torsten Frings bei Darmstadt 98. Wie das alles kam, besprechen wir gleich. Aber jetzt sage ich erstmal Hallo, Björn. Vielen Dank, dass das geklappt hat. Das hoffe ich doch auch. Unter anderem auch deshalb, weil wir Tobias Escher auch bei uns in der Runde begrüßen dürfen. Tobi Escher, Freund des Hauses Rasenfunk, kann man glaube ich inzwischen bezeichnen, fast so eine Art Dauergast heute mit dabei. Nicht nur, weil ich ihn sehr schätze und immer zu allem seine Meinungen hören möchte, sondern weil er sich mit dem Komplex der Fußballtrainer ganz intensiv befasst hat. Er hat ein Buch geschrieben, Die Zeit der Strategen, wie Guardiola, Löw, Mourinho und Co. den Fußball neu denken, erschien bei Rowohlt und sehr, sehr, sehr empfehlenswert. Liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, Tobi, schön, dass du mit dabei bist. Ja, wie immer ist es eine Win-Win-Situation, zumindest hoffentlich. Und wenn wir eh schon beim Bedanken sind, dann danke ich auch Axel, Ed, Penny, unterstrich, Lane, Ed, nein, einfach nur Maria, Matthias und Marvin Michel. Sie alle sind Rasenfunk-Supporter. Der Rasenfunk ist ein Hobby, das zum Beruf wurde. Wir sind Sponsoren, Sponsoren paywall und werbefrei. Das heißt allein die Hörerinnen und Hörer finanzieren das alles. Herzlichen Dank an diejenigen, die das schon tun. Diejenigen, die sich dafür interessieren können, das mal sich näher anschauen unter rasenfunk.de unterstützen. Und für alle Supporterinnen und Supporter da draußen, die sich bereits registriert haben als Supporter unter rasenfunk.de rsc, wir verlosen ein Buch von Tobi. Die Zeit der Strategen verlosen wir unter euch. Registriert euch noch. Ich würde sagen, eine Woche nachdem das hier online gegangen ist, werde ich dann mal die E-Mail rumschicken, wie das genau funktioniert. Und dann können wir wenigstens einen kleinen Dank an die Supporterinnen und Supporter zurückgeben. Mit diesem wirklich sehr empfehlenswerten Buch. So, das soll es aber genug der Vorrede gewesen sein. Ich würde sagen, lass uns mal ein bisschen allgemein anfangen, Björn. Welche Bedeutung haben denn für dich Trainer im Fußball?
Also Trainer sind die Gesichter der Vereine und damit haben sie eine sehr, sehr hohe Bedeutung. Jeder, der in der Bundesliga einen Verein vor Augen hat, hat gleich den Cheftrainer vor Augen. Und somit ist der Fokus dort auch ganz klar auf den Trainer gelegt. Es wird gehört, was er sagt, wie er es sagt. Hält er eine Brandrede in einer Pressekonferenz, äußert er sich womöglich auch mal politisch mittlerweile auch, wie ist er in den sozialen Medien unterwegs. Also Trainer ist das Gesicht des Vereins und mit die wichtigste Personalie, nicht nur bei Profi-Vereinen, auch in höheren Amateurklassen, sehr wichtige Personalie.
Tobi, du hast jetzt ein Buch über Trainer geschrieben, das heißt, so ganz klein kannst du deren Bedeutung auch nicht sehen. Wo würdest du denn sagen, im sportlichen Bereich ist da der moderne Trainer heutzutage noch so mächtig wie früher, hat sich da was verändert in seiner Bedeutung?
Ich glaube schon, dass der Trainer noch sehr, sehr bedeutend ist. Im sportlichen Bereich auf jeden Fall. Ein Trainer ist ja ein Berufsbild, das sehr komplex ist. Also man kann halt nicht sagen, dass der Trainer nur eine Aufgabe hat. Ein Trainer ist immer in erster Linie auch ein Fachmann für das Sportliche. Er muss das Training gestalten, er muss sich darum kümmern, dass so eine Spieler fit sind. Er muss sich darum kümmern, dass seine Spieler sich nicht verletzen, dass seine Spieler eine Taktik haben. Ein Trainer ist auch mal ein Taktiker. Also ein Trainer ist auch der Chef, der sich überlegen muss, welche Taktik er macht. Ein Trainer ist im Fitnessbereich sehr viel zugänglich. Ein Trainer ist aber auch ein Menschenführer. Der Trainer ist ja derjenige, der am Ende entscheidet, wer spielt und der muss darum sich kümmern, dass die Leute, die spielen, gut drauf sind und dass die, die nicht spielen, auch gut drauf sind. Das ist auch immer als Psychologe gefragt. Und das, was Björn gerade schon gesagt hat, ein Trainer ist auch immer, zumindest in den höheren Bereichen, ein Medienmann, ein Mann, der in der Öffentlichkeit steht und der sich da auch verkaufen muss. Also ist das schon mal zumindest ein sehr komplexes Berufsbild, das in den letzten Jahren auch immer komplexer wurde, weil halt diese einzelnen Teilbereiche des Fußballs immer komplexer wurden.
Wenn ich als ergänzen darf, wir hatten im Fußballlehrerlehrerlehrung immer ein schönes Bild, da war der Christian Streich mit seiner Freiburger Mannschaft, hat er ein Orchester besucht und da gibt es ein Bild. Das Bild ist eigentlich gut dargestellt für die Aufgabe eines Trainers. Er ist wie ein Dirigent. Er muss ein ganzes Orchester leiten, das ist nicht nur seine Mannschaft, das ist mittlerweile ein großes Team ums Team herum, ein großer Staff. Er muss auf verschiedenen Klaviaturen spielen können, muss die Presse bedienen, muss das Präsidium bedienen, muss womöglich Sponsoren bedienen, muss vor allen Dingen Medienarbeit auch leisten. Und das fand ich immer ein schönes Bild. Der Trainer ist im Prinzip ein Dirigent dieses ganzen Geschäfts und ergänzend, was die besondere Stellung eines Trainers im Profibereich ist, dass seine Arbeit von so vielen Menschen bewertet wird, die gar nicht explizit wissen können, was er denn täglich überhaupt macht. Also da sind 50.000 Menschen im Stadion und es sind natürlich 50.000 Trainer, sag ich mal, weil jeder irgendwie schon mal vor die Kugel getreten hat oder ein Trainer gibt eine Pressekonferenz nach dem Spiel und das wird dann letztendlich bewertet, seine Arbeit. Aber wer ist schon tagtäglich auf dem Platz? Wer ist im Büro? Und das ist, denke ich, eine Ausnahmestellung, welchen Beruf gibt es, der so stark bewertet wird in der Öffentlichkeit? Vielleicht von Vorständen, von großen Konzernen noch, aber ansonsten gibt es wenig Berufszweige, die so stark bewertet werden von Leuten, die gar nicht dabei sind.
Und trotzdem gibt es immer wieder das Klischee, es gäbe bestimmte Mannschaften, die sind so gut in ihrer personellen Qualität, Tobi, die bräuchten gar keinen Trainer.
Ja, das gibt es immer wieder. Das ist auch wieder die Croaks und das ist auch das, was ich versuche, in dem Buch, das ich geschrieben habe, zu beschreiben, dass jede Mannschaft einen anderen Trainer braucht. Also es gibt Mannschaften, ich sehe es bei Real Madrid, die haben ein so hohes individuelles Niveau, da ist die Arbeit eines Trainers eine ganz andere. Weil da geht es dann darum, diese Spieler, die schon alle nahezu perfekt Fußball spielen, die musst du nicht mehr entwickeln, sondern die musst du nur noch irgendwie bei Laune halten und halbwegs ein taktisches Konzept einbringen. Dann gibt es das, was Christian Streich, den wir gerade schon genannt haben, in Freiburg machen muss, der hat eine ganz andere Aufgabe. Der hat keine Mannschaft, die auf dem individuellen hohen Niveau ist, der muss keine Pressekonferenzen leiten, bei denen 100 Journalisten anwesend sind. Da sitzen dann in dem kleinen Buch zehn Journalisten und dann redet man eher, das ist dann eine ganz andere Form. Dann ist es halt auch, ich würde nicht sagen, fast schon ein anderer Beruf, aber es ist dann schon ein sehr großer Unterschied, was dann die Rolle eines Trainers ist bei dem Verein.
Siehe das Buch, ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das auch gelesen habt, von Carlo Ancelotti, bevor er zu Bayern kam, Quiet Leadership. Auch sehr interessant, das ist genau das, was du beschreibst, Tobi. Er vornehmlich Mannschaften trainiert hat, die über eine herausragende Qualität von Einzelspielern verfügte und er eher in dieser Menschenführungsrolle war. Wenngleich natürlich seine fachliche Qualität uns nicht anzuzweifeln ist, aber er musste eher das Team führen, er musste auch den 14. 15. Superstar führen. Und komischerweise hat das bei Bayern anscheinend nicht geklappt, aber das ist eben der Typ Trainer, den du gerade eben auch beschrieben hast, wenn du große Teams trainierst.
Ja, das ist auch so ein interessanter Punkt, es gibt ja jeder Verein hat ja auch eine eigene Philosophie, was Trainer angeht, also die Spieler haben ja durch das, was sie vom Verein gewohnt sind, eine bestimmte Erwartung an einen Trainer, auch wenn da sehr viel Fluktuation herrscht, aber in München hast du da wahrscheinlich eine andere Erwartung als in Madrid. Ich habe jetzt mit meinem Kollegen Martin Raffel von Spielverlagerung geredet, der arbeitet aktuell in Kroatien und der meinte, da muss ich auch erstmal umgewöhnen, weil die Spieler haben eine andere Erwartung an Taktik als in Deutschland, weil der Begriff Taktik in Kroatien einfach ganz anders geprägt ist als in Deutschland. Das sind dann so kleine Umstellungen, aber das ist dann natürlich wieder sehr im Detail drin. Aber da sind natürlich überall unterschiedliche Formen des Trainerdaseins.
Ja, unglaublich viele verschiedene Typen gibt es. Also gerade wenn man Quiet Leadership von Carlo Ancelotti liest, da hat man zwischenzeitlich den Eindruck, dass es eigentlich so ein Unternehmensberaterbuch ist, das einem Techniken mitgeben soll, wie man ein Unternehmen führt. Also da muss man sich immer wieder vor Augen halten, es geht hier eigentlich um Fußballvereine und er hat aber damit sehr großen Erfolg gehabt. Gleichzeitig haben wir aber auch, vor allem bei vielleicht weniger prominenten und qualitativ stark besetzten Vereinen, ganz, ganz andere Trainertypen und all das muss ja in eine Ausbildung gegossen werden, zumindest versucht werden, dieses allrounder Wissen, was Trainer brauchen und diese ganz verschiedenen Typen, die es auch auf dem Trainermarkt gibt, in eine Ausbildung zu gießen. Ich bin sehr gespannt darauf, Björn, wie du uns dann später erklärst, wie man das beim DFB derzeit angeht, aber vorher würde ich gerne mit dir drüber sprechen, wie war denn so dein Werdegang? Wann kam bei dir die Entscheidung, selbst Trainer zu werden? Und sag jetzt nicht, du hast schon in Trainerbettwäsche geschlafen.
Nee, überhaupt nicht, nein, nein, nein. Also ich habe, wie du schon gesagt hast, auf höherem Amateurniveau gespielt, war als Jugendlicher ganz talentiert, habe auch mal Jugendnationalmannschaft gespielt, aber es hat nicht zum Profi gereicht, also bis Regionalliga gespielt. Da verdienst du auch schon ein bisschen Geld und das war mein Glück, dass ich mein Studium dadurch finanzieren konnte. Also ich habe eben Sport studiert und relativ früh auch durch diese Tätigkeit, durch das Sportstudium, Freude daran gehabt, eben auch Mannschaft zu trainieren. Also parallel zu meinem Fußball-Dasein, Fußballer-Dasein eben auch immer schon mal Jugendmannschaften trainiert. Sei es als Co-Trainer oder bin noch mal mitgelaufen oder in Fußballferienschulen gearbeitet. So bin ich da irgendwie reingewachsen, sage ich mal. Und ja, bin dann nach meinem Sportstudium, wo du dann nicht so richtig weißt, was willst du jetzt oder was machst du jetzt damit eigentlich. Das ist jetzt so der typische Karriereweg, den du planen kannst, habe ich mich herumgehört und dann auch Stellenanzeigen durchforcet und bin dann auf eine Stelle als Jugendkoordinator in Baden-Württemberg bei einem ganz kleinen Verein gestoßen und hatte dort so meine erste hauptamtliche Stelle als Jugendkoordinator, als ja auch Trainer von jeweils zwei Mannschaften, habe selbst auch noch gekickt nebenher und das war uneinemlich lehrreich, weil ich mich so komplett ausleben konnte. Also ich musste irgendwie alles machen und alles von der Pike auf lernen, hatte niemanden eigentlich an der Seite, der es mir beibringt, weil ich der einzige Hauptamtliche in dem kleinen Dorfverein war und es war einfach eine sehr interessante Tätigkeit und bin danach durch eine Stellenausschreibung eben zum Hamburger Fußballverband gekommen und bin das erste Mal so richtig eingetaucht in dann eben auch den Leistungsfußball, weil ich dort eben auch Auswahlmannschaften betreut habe. Ich hatte unter anderem das Glück, den Jonathan Tarr und Lewin Öztonali fünf Jahre in der Hamburger Auswahl zu betreuen, habe heute auch noch Kontakt zu den beiden und war dort eben auch schon in der Trainerausbildung tätig, eben auf dem Niveau, was wir dann gleich eben durchgehen in der Ausbildungspyramide und über diese Tätigkeit habe ich die Voraussetzung erfüllt, überhaupt mich zu bewerben für den Fußballlehrer, die A-Lizenz habe ich schon relativ früh machen können, während meines Studiums schon, ja und habe den Fußballlehrer gemacht und habe genetzwerkt und dann war plötzlich kurz nach meinem Abschluss auch eine Stelle frei dort und dann, wie das so ist, da kennst du die Leute und bist irgendwie drin im Kreislauf und so dann eben auch zum DFB gekommen.
Ja, also jetzt sind wir schon ein bisschen durchgaloppiert durch deine Karriere. Was mich noch interessieren würde, du hast selbst gespielt von 1996 bis 2005, später dann nochmal bei der SG Empfing, das hast du ja gerade schon angesprochen, nochmal so in einer Doppelrolle als Trainer und Spieler, aber eben 96 bis 2005 ist so der Hauptzeitraum, da hat sich ja einiges im Fußball getan und da wirst du doch vermutlich auch auf ganz unterschiedliche Trainertypen selbst als Spieler gestoßen sein. Gab es da welche, an denen du dich orientiert hast, in positiven oder negativen?
Das ja, das erste Mal, dass ich wirklich so richtig Taktiktraining mitbekommen habe, war beim ersten FC Bocholt, da war Trainer Fritz Bischoff, der war auch vorher mal Trainer beim DFB und ich weiß jetzt im Nachhinein, dass er in Italien hospitiert hatte und da ging es das erste Mal für mich um sowas wie verschieben, um raumorientiert, ballorientiert zu verschieben. Das war ganz neu für mich und sehr prägend, sehr viel gelernt und als Spieler habe ich das das erste Mal mitbekommen und zwar haben wir da in der Jugend bei Bayer Öding damals noch gespielt, gegen Gladbach gespielt und Bernd Kraus war Trainer und der hat dort das erste Mal mit Viererkette gespielt. Ich war dort in der Jugend noch offensiv und ich kannte das nicht, gegen eine Viererkette zu spielen und ich bin überall rumgelaufen, aber da war nirgendwo ein freier Raum, aber mir ist auch nie ein Gegenspieler hinterher gelaufen. Das war ganz, ganz komisch.
Wann war denn das in welchem Jahr?
So 1995, 1996. Das war das erste Mal, dass ich gegen eine Viererkette gespielt habe und das war schon sehr innovativ damals für den Jugendbereich. Das waren so die zwei Dinge, wo ich sage, das war schon prägend und die sind mir in Erinnerung geblieben, wo es so richtig erst mal um taktische Dinge ging.
Ja da ist 95, glaube ich, auch relativ früh Tobi für Viererkette im deutschen Fußball, wenn jetzt auch im Nachwuchsbereich.
Ja ich glaube auch. Ich überlege gerade nochmal, ja aber es gab dann schon die erste Anplanung in diesem Jahr auch im Profifußball, aber das waren auch noch andere Viererketten als heute, muss man wahrscheinlich dazu sagen. Ja, aber es war schon ziemlich früh und innovativ. Was heißt früh und innovativ für Deutschland? Deutschland war ja bei dieser Viererkettennummer mindestens fünf Jahre zu spät dran eigentlich. Eigentlich eher zehn, sodass man dann sagen kann, international wäre es wahrscheinlich nicht innovativ gewesen, in Italien oder so.
Ja, dass Deutsche da ein bisschen hinten dran ist, wird glaube ich heute oder hinten dran war zumindest, wird heute immer mal wieder nochmal im Subtext Thema werden. Gibt ja auch einen Grund, warum die Ausbildung zum Fußballlehrer so ist, wie sie jetzt gerade ist. Aber sag mal Björn, wenn du so deine eindrücklichen Erlebnisse rund um Taktik beschreibst, dann würde ich dich als ein Spieler einschätzen, der schon früh um die Bedeutung von Taktik wusste. Wie wird denn das innerhalb von Mannschaften aufgenommen, wenn Trainer mit Taktik kommen? Gerade so in dieser Phase, um die wir jetzt sprechen, nämlich so um die Jahrtausendwende, als das eben noch nicht so etabliert war. Heutzutage kommen die Leute, glaube ich, schon mit einem anderen Wissen in die Vereine und sind auch selbst ein bisschen kompetenter, was Taktik angeht. Aber wie waren die Reaktionen damals, wenn dann eben auf einmal im Raum verschieben geübt wurde und nicht mit dem – ich spreche jetzt plakativ – Medizinball, solange durch den Wald gerannt wurde, bis ein Drittel der Mannschaft sich übergeben hat?
Das war toll, weil man konkrete Aufgaben an die Hand bekommen hat. Und das war ja, wie du eben sagst, was Neues. Vorher war es, ja, ich sag mal, so ein bisschen das altbackene Training. Es ging viel um körperliche Dinge, konditionelle Dinge. Und dann, ja, geht's raus und spiel's Fußball, so à la Franz Beckenbauer. Also man hat wenig detaillierte – es wurde die Aufstellung an die Wand geschmettert und dann wurden ein paar Hinweise gegeben. Aber so dieses taktische, eine Aufgabe an die Hand zu bekommen, selbst wenn der Ball nicht in deiner Nähe ist, das ist ja oftmals die Herausforderung. Also der Ball ist irgendwie 40 Meter entfernt und du hast trotzdem eine Aufgabe, nämlich du musst den Raum eng machen, musst zum Ball verschieben, musst trotzdem deinen Mitspieler im Blick haben. Das war super. Also da habe ich jetzt keine Misstöne oder keine negativen Kommentare irgendwie gespeichert bei mir, sondern ganz im Gegenteil.
Also auch innerhalb der Mannschaften kam das gut an? Na ist ja interessant. Und dann bist du eben bei der SG Empfingen – allein, dass sie noch mal genannt ist, wollte ich das noch mal sagen – bist du dann so ein bisschen in den Nachwuchs reingegangen und dann zum Hamburger Fußballverband gekommen. Sag uns mal, wie hat sich denn dein Blick auf den Fußball verändert durch dein Studium und dann, dass du zum ersten Mal nicht derjenige warst, der die Anweisungen empfangen hat und der einfach nur zugehört hat, wie sieht die Trainingsübung aus, sondern der sich überlegen musste, ich möchte etwas Bestimmtes erreichen mit einer Trainingsübung. Wie könnte die denn jetzt aussehen?
Ja, der Blick hat sich immens verändert. Also da muss ich auch sagen, dass ich zu Beginn der Tätigkeit beim Hamburger Fußballverband – ja, also ich habe in der Zeit sehr, sehr viel gelernt. Also der damalige Verbandssportlehrer, Uwe Jahn – schön Gruß, wenn du das hörst – da habe ich sehr, sehr viel von ihm gehört, so eine Art Mentor auch gewesen. Lange Jahre in dem Geschäft gewesen und ich bin immer mit gespitzen Ohren rumgelaufen. Jede Taktikbesprechung, sei es oder jede Mannschaftsbesprechung, war einfach lehrreich für mich. Und dann eben selber verantwortlich vor den Jungs zu stehen und sich Dinge zu überlegen, nachher festzustellen. Oh, da hast du aber vielleicht ins Klo gegriffen, das machst du beim nächsten Mal aber anders oder dann sogar Fortschritte bei der Mannschaft, bei einzelnen Spielern zu sehen. Das hat einfach Spaß gemacht und hat den Blick natürlich total verändert. Viele Ex-Profis sagen, der Beruf des Spielers ist der schönste Beruf. Und das ist auch so, weil du mit nichts was am Hut hast. Du gehst auf den Platz, da ist ein Trainer, der sagt dir, was du tun sollst. Und klar, du musst auf dem Platz einige Entscheidungen treffen. Dazu brauchst du Mut und da musst du auch auch auch auch kleiner Birne sein. Aber als Trainer machst du dir um so viel mehr Gedanken. Mit wem sprichst du heute? Wen spreche ich heute mal extra nicht an? Wer kriegt mal einen schärferen Ton? Wer braucht die Streicheleinheiten? Mache ich heute wieder was an der Taktik-Tafel oder haben die Jungs die Taktik-Tafel satt? Mache ich eine Videoanalyse? Lasse ich heute mal Taktik komplett sein, weil sie übersättigt sind? Du machst dir so viele Gedanken. Du bist immer, wie der Tobi auch schon anfangs sagte, Hobbypsychologe oder vielleicht sogar hauptberuflich Psychologe. Du machst dir immer ständig Gedanken um das Wohl der Truppe und was ist der beste Impuls, den du jetzt den Spielern geben kannst. Und da kannst du auch nicht pauschalisieren. Nicht der beste Impuls für die Mannschaft, sondern ich sage ganz konkret für die Spieler, weil jeden muss da auch anders ansprechen.
Hattest du mal so richtige Grenzgänger oder Querschläger in deinen Mannschaften mit dabei? Es gibt ja Individualisten. Ich will das gar nicht negativ behaftet sehen, sondern es gibt Menschen, die machen lieber ihr eigenes Ding und das gibt es auch im Fußball. Und das braucht es ja ein Stück weit auch im Fußball. Wie bist du denn damit umgegangen? Oder hattest du gar nicht so die Spieler, die da mal so auch ein bisschen aus der Gruppe ausgebrochen sind?
Ja, gerade in der Zeit beim Hamburger Fußballverband mit den Auswahlmannschaften, das waren dann irgendwann Teenager, die natürlich andere Flausen auch im Kopf haben. Das waren die besten Talente aus Hamburg, vor allem vom HSV in St. Pauli. Und natürlich gab es da auch Spieler, die ihr eigenes Ego in den Vordergrund stellen wollten. Und natürlich hat man dann probiert, durch Gespräche sie einzufangen, sie in den Mannschaftskreis zu integrieren, ihnen klar zu machen, dass es nur miteinander geht. Aber wie du schon sagst, manchen musst du auch einfach eine lange Leine lassen, damit sie ihre individuellen Qualitäten, die vielleicht besser sind als bei anderen, dann der Mannschaft auch helfen. Und da gibt es, glaube ich, auch kein Pauschalrezept, wie du das machst. Ich glaube, der Julian Nagelsmann hat mal im Podcast gehört, auch über den Sandro Wagner so gesprochen und ist ja auch ein Freigeist, würde ich ihn mal nennen, den du vielleicht anders händelst als jemand anderes. Und wenn du ihn anders händelst, er seine Stärken einfach viel besser einbringen kannst auch. Und das ist eben die große Kunst, glaube ich, die Menschen kennenzulernen, die dahinterstecken. Es ist nicht nur der Spieler, sondern eben auch der Mensch. Wie sprichst du ihn an? Wie ist er empfänglich für Informationen?
Ja, Horst Rubisch hat mal erzählt, es gibt bei ihm ein striktes Handyverbot in den UNationalmannschaften. Und er hat dann mal später in einem Interview gesagt, naja, das hat auch einen gruppenbildenden Faktor. Wenn sich nämlich die Spieler gegenseitig am Bahnhof sagen, Achtung gleich kommt, der Rubisch packt dein Handy weg, dann schweißt sie das ja auch irgendwie zusammen. Das fand ich interessant, wie so eine Maßnahme, die nach außen hin erstmal aussieht, wie sehr streng und ist sie ja auch und sehr konsequent und vielleicht auch ein bisschen in Anführungszeichen altbacken, dann aber noch mal einen ganz anderen psychologischen Effekt hat.
Und trotzdem ist der Horst Rubisch jemand, der sich dann auch aufs Zimmer setzt. Und bei elektronischen Dingen gerne die Spieler fragt, ach hier, das ist ja neu, zeig mir mal. Also der ist dann trotzdem auch offen dafür und fängt sie dadurch dann auch wieder ein. Also Horst Rubisch ist schon ein krasser Menschenfänger und einer, der sicherlich über die Schiene Menschenführung einfach sehr viel Mannschaftsspirit entwickeln kann und da ganz viele Prozentpunkte sicherlich auch noch rausgeholt hat. Nicht umsonst hat er auch eben die Titel geholt mit den unnationalen Mannschaften. Das ist natürlich immer noch mal eine besondere Herausforderung für so einen überschaubaren Zeitrahmen bei so einem Turnier, so eine richtig gute Truppe zusammenzustellen. Also einerseits nach außen hin, macht mal die Handys weg, aber dann auch im kleinen Kreis hier, zeig mir mal, wie funktioniert das überhaupt mit Facebook.
Und wir haben auch gelernt, ich weiß nicht, ob ihr die Pressekonferenz zu viel ich gesehen habe von Christian Streich, das war so rund um den 32. 33. Spieltag der 2017er, 2018er Saison, da hat er gesagt, er wisse jetzt seit einer Woche, was WhatsApp ist, weil nämlich bei irgendeinem Journalisten der WhatsApp-Ton zu hören war. Das war dann auch interessant, dass man das so spät kennenlernen kann, aber es erinnert einen ja so ein bisschen an die eigenen Eltern und es muss ja auch überhaupt nichts Schlimmes sein. Aber über Technikaffinität, glaube ich, werden wir auch noch häufiger heute reden. Tobi, wenn wir so über diese gruppenpsychologischen Aspekte sprechen, da komme ich immer schnell an den Punkten, über den ich mit dir auch schon häufiger jetzt auch schon im Rasenfunk diskutiert habe. Dürfen denn dann Menschen wie wir zwei, also ich als Moderator eines Fußballpodcasts, du als Fußballexperte im Grunde in allen Medien, die es da draußen so gibt. Dürfen wir denn eigentlich über Fußball reden, ohne uns selbst in Psychologie weitergebildet zu haben oder ohne so gewisse Einblicke zu haben, die natürlich eigentlich fast unmöglich zu bekommen sind, wenn dann nur Gerüchte halber – und das will man ja eigentlich journalistisch auch nicht weiterverarbeiten?
Ich finde es immer schwierig, eben weil wir diesen Einblick nicht haben, man kann sie natürlich in Psychologie weiterbilden, wobei die theoretische Psychologie jetzt noch was ganz anderes als die praktische Anwendung ist. Das sind dann nochmal ganz unterschiedliche Themen und auch ganz unterschiedliche Ausbildungswege, die man da gehen müsste, aber es ist natürlich immer schwierig von außen, gerade in der modernen Fußballwelt, die ja sehr abgeschottet auch ist, dann etwas zum Innenleben der Mannschaft zu sagen, weil man dann auch sehr schnell auf Klischees vertraut, bei dem man dann Spielern so klischeehafte Rollen zuteilwird, die ja im echten Leben sehr viel komplexer sind als das, was wir ihnen dann zugestehen teilweise. Deswegen versuche ich, dass es auch immer so gut geht, aus meiner Arbeit rauszuhalten, auch wenn es natürlich nicht immer ganz funktioniert.
Aber macht dich das nicht wahnsinnig, dass man das Gefühl hat, egal wie sehr wir uns mit dem Fußball beschäftigen und egal wir versuchen, uns auf das Sportliche zu konzentrieren, irgendwie kennt man immer nur die halbe Wahrheit und dann gibt jemand nach seinem Karriereende ein Interview und erzählt Anekdoten rund, was so in den Mannschaften passiert ist, in denen er gespielt hat, worum sich gedacht hat, ja, das erklärt auch im Nachhinein so einiges. Schade, dass wir damals das nicht in die Bewertung mit einbeziehen konnten.
Ja, das stimmt. Andererseits haben natürlich auch Fußballspieler wieder, wo der gerade schon sehr gut rausgearbeitet hat, haben wieder einen ganz anderen Blick auf das Spiel und jeder Teil des Spiels, also Trainer, Spieler, aber auch wir als Journalisten, sage ich mal, neigen dazu, sich selbst zu überschätzen und ihren Beitrag selbst zu überschätzen. Das muss ja dann, manchmal sind das auch Anekdoten, die halt vielleicht witzig sind, aber die haben ja auch immer, die wahrscheinlich dann relativ wenig damit zu tun hatten, warum Brasilien dann plötzlich 7-1 einbricht oder sowas. Das ist ja schon sehr viel komplexer, das Spiel, als dass man es dann auch mit solchen Kleinigkeiten erklären kann.
Aber deswegen ist es auch das Deutschen liebstes Baby, weil irgendwie kann ja jeder, jetzt nicht nur Journalisten, sondern eben auch jeder, der im Stadion ist oder der sich für Fußball interessiert, irgendwie kann ja jeder ein bisschen mitreden, weil wie vorhin schon gesagt, vor die Kugel getreten hat fast jeder schon mal irgendwie, sei es in der Mannschaft oder auch nur beim Straßenkick. Und darum kann man sich vielleicht eher eine Meinung bilden, als jetzt über ein Baseballspiel, was ich mir anschaue oder Basketballspiel, was ich jetzt auf hohem Niveau nie irgendwie gemacht habe. Das macht es ja auch so interessant.
Und wie empfindest du als jemand, der selbst ja dann auch später bei Darmstadt 98 in einer sehr bewegten Phase, nämlich zur Rückrunde der Saison 2016, 2017 der Erstliga-Saison, wurdest du da Co-Trainer von Torsten Frings, also du hast das selbst auch erlebt. Wie empfindest du die Berichterstattung rund um die Arbeit von Fußballtrainern?
Ich war jetzt nicht überrascht, weil man ist ja Kante aus der Sicht desjenigen, der selber sich gerne über Fußball informiert. Also das ist einfach Teil des Geschäfts. Das weißt du, wenn du das machst. Du weißt, dass es einfach ein Tagesgeschäft ist. Es ist wirklich so vom Gefühl auch selbst, wenn du das Wochenende das Spiel gewonnen hast, dann fährst du eine komplette Woche anders zum Training, weil die Medien auch anders drauf sind, als wenn du jetzt drei Spiele hintereinander verloren hast. Dann fährst du anders die Woche zum Training. Das stimmt schon. Das ist ein anderes Gefühl. Das erlebt zu haben, war eine wertvolle Erfahrung, aber dass die Medien jetzt so berichten, wie sie berichten, das ist so. Was ich gemerkt habe an der Arbeit mit Torsten, der da wirklich sehr viel Erfahrung hatte, aus seiner Zeit auch als Spieler und eben auch aus seiner Q-Trainer-Tätigkeit bei Werder Bremen, dass er da die Medien sehr gut gespielt hat, auch ein sehr gutes Verhältnis hatte zu den Medien und durchaus auch das ein oder andere Mal dann off the record dann Kontra gegeben hat und durchaus auch mal den ein oder anderen zur Seite geholt hat und Dinge einfach mal klargestellt hat, ohne dass das jetzt dann am nächsten Tag irgendwo in der Presse stand, sondern im vertrauensvollen Verhältnis. Also es ist immer auch ein Geben und Nehmen, glaube ich, als Cheftrainer. Jetzt war ich auf dem Niveau noch nicht Cheftrainer und das ist sicherlich auch eine ganz, ganz große Herausforderung und da gehst du sicherlich mit dem einen oder anderen Gedanken ins Bett und stehst mit dem auf und wühlst dich nachts hin und her, wie du da Dinge vielleicht wieder einfangen kannst, wenn sie aus dem Ruder geraten sind.
Das, was mir mal ein Trainer gesagt hat, fand ich sehr interessant. Er meinte jetzt überspitzt gesagt, der einzige Unterschied, ob du in der vierten Liga oder an der ersten Liga oder an der Jugend trainierst, ist dann tatsächlich auf dem Niveau die Medienarbeit. Weil die Inhalte sind, wenn du nicht gerade die Bayern trainierst, sind bei den meisten Trainern ähnlich. Die meisten Trainer haben ja ihre Inhalte und die sich dann nur marginal abändern. Aber das, was halt der Große knackt, ist dann die Medienarbeit, die halt einfach dir das dreifache Zeitwerk frisst.
Genau. Und natürlich auch die Qualität, die du hast, also die Qualität an Spielern, die du – klar, Bayern München nochmal als Highlight-Beispiel, aber ob du nur im Amateurbereich trainierst oder im Profibereich – das Niveau der Spieler ist ein anderes, somit kannst du vielleicht auch anders ansetzen. Aber im Groben hast du genau recht. Die Inhalte, die groben Überschriften für Trainingseinheiten sind dieselben. Aber du hast halt nicht eine Pressekonferenz mit einem Journalisten, sondern mit ein paar mehr. Das stimmt. Und das, was du sagst, das, was wir eingangs auch festgestellt haben, das, was du sagst, findet einfach mehr Beachtung. Du musst einfach ein bisschen vorsichtiger sein auch.
Da springe ich jetzt mal ein bisschen vor und dann gleich wieder zurück. Wird man denn auf diesen Umgang mit Medien vorbereitet? Von Spielern wissen wir, dass sie schon in sehr jungem Alter inzwischen darauf vorbereitet werden, wie sie sich selbst präsentieren gegenüber Medien und auch via Social-Media-Netzwerke. Gibt es das im Bereich der Trainer-Ausbildung auch?
Ja, das ist ein großer Part in der Fußballlehrerausbildung, das ist sogar ein eigener Block. Da gibt es im Prinzip eine Lehrgangsphase. Das ist ein reines Rhetorikseminar. Da kommen Journalisten, also zum Beispiel auch ein Sky-Kommentator oder auch von den Printmedien und es wird in Rollenspielen verschiedene Szenarien dargestellt. Also die Printmedien interviewen einen Trainerkandidaten dort und stellen ganz fiese Fragen und verdrehen ihm die Sätze quasi im Mund und machen dann eine Bildschlagzeile raus, was dabei rauskommen könnte. Oder eine Pressekonferenz wird nachgestellt. Also da wird man darauf vorbereitet, einerseits in einem Extraseritorikseminar und – da kommen wir später auch noch drauf zu sprechen – also eigentlich während der gesamten zehnmonatigen Ausbildung wirst du permanent – wir haben es immer genannt – gespiegelt, du wirst selber aufgenommen, du bekommst ein Feedback darüber, wie stehst du vor einer Gruppe – das ist jetzt keine Pressearbeit – aber wie hältst du eine Ansprache vor der Mannschaft oder wie hältst du einen Vortrag – da bekommst du permanent Feedback und dadurch nimmst du halt sehr, sehr viel auch mit. Aber was passiert danach, dann bist du drinnen im – gibt es dann noch Schulungen und da gibt es sicherlich auch Trainer, die sicherlich vielleicht auch Mediaberater an der Seite haben, weil das einfach auch ein wichtiges Feld ist.
Ja, ganz sicher.
Finde ich sehr spannend. Bin ich gespannt, wie das weitergegeben kommen wird, ehrlich gesagt. Ohne jetzt so zum Thema abschweifen zu wollen, aber man merkt ja doch schon eine gewisse Müdigkeit in der Öffentlichkeit mit der Art der Rhetorik, wie sie aktuell von Fußball-Trainern und Spielern gelebt wird. Ich glaube, dass wir da wieder ein bisschen den Weg wegsehen werden, hin zu Authentizität und auch zu Aussagen, die kontroverser sind.
Ich weiß es nicht. Andererseits kriegst du es so lange um die Ohren gehauen, selbst wenn du eigentlich vielleicht zu deiner Aussage einen abmilderten Kontext geliefert hast, wird es halt doch häufig aus dem Kontext gerissen und dann hast du – ich glaube, viele Trainer hätten jetzt auch gar nicht so sehr das Problem mit Björn, da würde mich deine Einschätzung interessieren, wenn sie mal mit eigenen konfrontativen Aussagen konfrontiert werden. Aber das Problem, was Trainer, glaube ich, dann mehr sehen oder was sie einfach nicht gebrauchen können, ist fünf Tage lang Ablenkung, sondern du willst einfach eigentlich deine Ruhe und deswegen schluckst du viele Dinge, viele Halbsätze, die du vielleicht gesagt hättest, einfach runter und da geht es dann gar nicht so sehr, dass alle es scheuen, dass sie selbst dann vielleicht Teil der Berichterstattung sind, vielleicht auch mal kritischer Berichterstattung, sondern eher darum, dass man sich denkt, nein, ich muss hier in Ruhe arbeiten können und wer weiß, wie groß das jetzt wieder gekocht wird. Das ist schwierig heutzutage einzuschätzen, wie hoch Dinge eskalieren.
Das stimmt. Das hat aber ein bisschen mit der Kultur der Fragestellung jetzt bei uns in Deutschland zu tun. Wenn man in Italien Trainer ist, dann wirst du mit ganz anderen Fragen konfrontiert. In Italien sind die Menschen oder auch die Journalisten vor allen Dingen taktisch unfassbar geschult – nicht weniger geschult als hier, aber dort ist es normal, dass sehr detaillierte Fragen gestellt werden zu taktischen Dingen. Ich weiß nicht, welcher Trainer, ob es Trappattoni oder Ancelotti war, die gesagt haben, das ist ja hier wie ein Paradies. Ich werde nur dazu befragt, spielt der Effenberg oder spielt der Scholl – oh, nee, der ist verletzt.
Das war Trappattoni, er hat das eine Anekdote erzählt.
Genau, genau. In Italien wirst du dann richtig auseinandergenommen und da ist es normal, dass über Dinge gespielt wird. Warum denn jetzt die hängenden Neuen und nicht mit zwei Spitzen? Das ist eine ganz andere Kultur. Ich glaube, Trainer würden hier vielleicht gerne mehrfachliche Dinge diskutieren, ohne dabei jetzt irgendwie ihre komplette Philosophie preiszugeben. Aber die Fragen werden häufig auch gar nicht gestellt.
Zwei Anmerkungen. Es funktioniert auch andersrum, wenn du das Italien-Beispiel nimmst. Antonio Conte hat damals als Nationaltrainer geworden, in Italien als erstes Mal sich sämtliche Nationalmannschaftsjournalisten eingeladen, hat denen eine 90-minutige Taktik-Präsentation gemacht. Das und das und das darauf müsst ihr achten. Das kannst du dir in Deutschland ja auch nicht vorstellen, dass sich ein Trainer das macht.
Favre hat das gemacht, mal in einer Pressekonferenz bei Hertha BSC, leider gibt es das nicht mehr bei YouTube, da hat er die Entstehung des 2 zu 1 dann hinten an der Sponsorenwand quasi mit Linien aufgezeichnet und hat dann kurz gezeigt, warum es falsch war. Es ging dann darum, dass der Weg der Flanke an der Torauslinie entlang, dass der offen gelassen wurde vom Verteidiger, dass er quasi sich einfach falsch positioniert hat. Deswegen war der Weg zur Flanke offen und deshalb ist es 2 zu 1 gefallen. Hat er in 30 perfekten Sekunden aufgezeichnet und hat gesagt, das war der eigentliche Fehler, nicht das, was Sie gerade angesprochen haben. Und dann hat er sich hingesetzt und hat gesagt, das hat Spaß gemacht, das sollten wir öfter machen. Das ist immer mein all-time favorite Lucien Favre im Moment.
Und den Ursprung hat es ja mit Ralf Rangnick im aktuellen Sportstudio. Aber ihm ist es nicht positiv behaftet, sondern er ist dadurch der Fußballprofessor geworden. Und das war so ein bisschen dann negativ behaftet, weil es einfach neu war. Man kannte es nicht, dass der Trainer in der Öffentlichkeit Taktik erklärt. Das war fremd, das war irgendwie befremdlich, obwohl es ja eigentlich super war. Und der Erste, der es salonfähig gemacht hat, war Jürgen Klopp während der WM, während der Berichterstattung. Da erbringt es natürlich in einem anderen Style rüber. Aber das war etwas, wo es wirklich salonfähig wurde.
Ja, das Randebeispiel wollte ich auch noch sagen, weil viele Trainer natürlich auch Angst haben, in Deutschland dann als Professor gesehen zu werden. Es gibt Trainer, die könnten tiefer in den Inhalt gehen, aber die wollen es nicht. Es gibt ja auch die andere Seite, dass Trainer sagen, ich möchte nicht dieses Professoren-Image haben, ich möchte als anderer Mensch wahrgenommen werden.
Ja, Image ist ein ganz wichtiges Thema, wenn man in der Öffentlichkeit steht. Ich persönlich habe ja so ein bisschen die Hoffnung, dass irgendwann mal – es gibt, glaube ich, Orte, da kann man sehr gut auch mal über Taktik reden und es gibt Orte, da klappt das nicht so gut. Also ich glaube, in einem Bild am Sonntag-Interview ist es schwieriger als jetzt zum Beispiel in einem Rasenfunk oder in auch anderen Podcasts. Also ich werde jetzt gar nicht nur über den Rasenfunk hier sprechen und vielleicht gibt es da einen breiteren Medienmix. Vielleicht werden es auch die eigenen Vereinsmedien irgendwann für sich mehr nutzen. Das ist dann die Frage, wie kritisch danach gefragt wird, aber vielleicht kriegen wir das in anderen Formaten mal in ein paar Jahren um die Ohren. Und ein zweiter Gedanke, den ich vorher noch hatte, ist, wann gibt es eigentlich den ersten Pressesprecher nur für den Trainer? Also Angela Merkel sitzt ja auch nicht mehr in der Bundespressekonferenz, sondern sie schickt da eben den Herrn Seibert hin. Stefan Seibert, vielleicht gibt es das dann im Fußballbereich auch irgendwann und dann auch die ähnlichen Floskeln, ja, das werden wir prüfen, das reichen wir noch nach, warum da jetzt der Sechser abgekippt ist, gucken wir uns noch mal im Detail an, müssen sie eine kleine Anfrage stellen, dann können wir uns gerade nicht zu Hause. Gut, wir sind ein bisschen vom Thema weggekommen, lasst uns mal jetzt Björn noch mal zu dem Zeitpunkt zurückkommen, in dem du dann zum DFB gewechselt bist, du warst vorher beim Hamburger Fußballverband, du hast schon gesagt, du hattest so ein bisschen ein gutes Timing und du hast ja selbst auch die Trainerlizenzen alle erworben bis zum Fußballlehrer. Nimm uns mal so ein bisschen mit, was hat dich denn überhaupt bewogen, bis zu diesem höchsten Spitzenfeld gehen zu wollen als Trainer?
Weil dann irgendwann für mich klar war, ich möchte hauptamtlich im Bereich Fußball arbeiten.
Was war da so attraktiv für dich?
Ja, weil ich mit Fußball groß geworden bin, mit fünf Jahren das erste Mal vor die Kugel getreten habe, bin im Fußball sportlich sozialisiert worden, habe Sport studiert und hatte Spaß an der Trainerarbeit, Spaß am Umgang mit Mannschaften. Und da habe ich jetzt gar nicht an den Profibereich gedacht – vielleicht war das mal ein ferner Traum, aber das war jetzt gar nicht so mein konkretes Ziel – sondern das war eine Phase, wo eben auch im Fußball ganz viele neue Arbeitsstellen geschaffen wurden. Früher war es so, da warst du Bundesligatrainer oder Zweitligatrainer, oder du warst bei einem Verband, Verbandssportlehrer, Ende. Mehr große Stellen gab es gar nicht. Und dann mit der Einführung der Nachwuchsleistungszentren gab es eine viel höhere Anzahl an Berufsfeldern, also hauptamtlicher U19-Trainer, Jugendkoordinator oder sportlicher Leiter in einem Nachwuchsleistungszentrum. An sowas hatte ich irgendwie gedacht. Und ja, wenn ich schon die A-Lizenz hatte und ein Sportstudium, dann wollte ich zumindest – nicht zumindest – dann wollte ich die höchste Lizenz haben, weil mir damit alle Wege halt offen standen. Wenn du die Lizenz hast, dann kannst du in jedem Bereich arbeiten, weil in manchen Bereichen du einfach nur mit Fußballlehrer-Lizenz arbeiten kannst. Und deswegen war das einfach für mich ein Ziel, diesen Schein zu machen, um einfach nochmal dieses komplette Wissen zu bekommen, also Lust darauf, nochmal ganz andere Facetten zu lernen, aber eben auch die Berechtigung zu haben. Danach steht mir alles offen, was so im Fußballbereich möglich ist.
Ich spiege dir mal mit einer kleinen Anekdote aus meinem Leben. Ich habe Germanistik, BWL und Politik studiert, Germanistik im Hauptfach und mein ehemaliger Germanistik-Studienleiter war quasi fassungslos, als er mich fragte, als ich mir mein Zeugnis abholte, dann als ich fertig war, meinte er so, ja wie geht es denn jetzt für Sie weiter und ich ihm sagte, ja ich bin schon seit einem Jahr als Sportredakteur tätig, ich wohne eigentlich auch gar nicht mehr in Freiburg, ich bin jetzt nur noch für die Prüfung hergekommen. Da ist ihm quasi die Brille aus seinem Gesicht gefallen und er hat sich so gefreut, weil er gesagt hat, sie sind ja super für meine Statistik, sie haben gerne mal nichts gegen den Hauptfach studiert und jetzt schon einen Job, das gibt es ja eigentlich gar nicht. Sprich, ich habe etwas studiert, wo sehr viele Leute die Ausbildung machen, aber es sehr wenige Betätigungsfelder gibt und beim Fußballlehrer lese ich jetzt zum Beispiel, es gibt 890 Fußballlehrer in Deutschland, das ist Stand 2017 war das, aber nur 56 Profivereine haben einen Job, jetzt gibt es auch diese anderen Betätigungsfelder, aber ist das nicht eigentlich eine ähnliche Konstellation, dass man die Ausbildung für etwas macht, in eine hohe Ungewissheit hinein, ob man wirklich eine dieser Stellen bekommt, denn auch diese Nachwuchskoordinate und sonstigen Stellen, die du genannt hast, sind ja nicht endlos.
Also ich sag mal das Klassische, du machst eine Ausbildung bei einer Bank und hast vor, in x Jahren Filialleiter zu werden, das kannst du vielleicht eher planen als sowas. Du, also auch meine Vita zeigt ja, du musst eigentlich da sein, wo der Job ist. Also bin dann schon auch nicht in einer Stadt geblieben, sondern auch da gewesen, wo der Job dann eben ist. Du brauchst ein hohes Maß an Flexibilität. Du musst immer wachsam sein, du musst Lust haben auf Neues und du weißt nicht, je höher du kommst und je professioneller es wird, weißt du nicht, was morgen ist. Also jetzt im höchsten Bereich, das was ich dann zum Schluss gemacht habe, als Co-Trainer einer Profimannschaft, da weißt du halt nicht, was in drei Wochen ist. Das kannst du nicht planen, das ist so.
Wobei aber auch natürlich auf dem Weg nach oben, wenn man den Fußballlehrer macht, da wird ja vorher schon sehr stark selektiert. Da kommen wir gleich wahrscheinlich zu, da landet der Geist. Es ist ja gar nicht so einfach, von ganz unten zu dem Fußballlehrer zu kommen. Und wenn du erstmal oben bist, dann hast du eigentlich schon was geleistet. Und du hast schon Erfahrung, hast auch schon ein Netzwerk, bis du erstmal oben bist. Deswegen, das ist schon so eine kleine Federung.
Okay, und stimmt auch ein großer Unterschied zum Germanistikstudium. Das muss ich offen zugeben, da wird zwar auch ausgesiebt, aber nicht so hart.
Ja, das stimmt. Also, um dem auch vorwegzugreifen, die Trainer, die den Fußballlehrer machen, die haben schon eine große Erfahrung an Trainerjahren hinter sich, weil sie eben auch die Lizenzen davor nicht hätten machen können, ohne überhaupt x Jahre in einem bestimmten Bereich auch trainiert zu haben. Also, da ist niemand Berufseinsteiger, sag ich mal so.
Gleichzeitig aber auch ein riskantes Betätigungsfeld. Also, es gibt ein Zitat von Lutz Hangartner, Präsident des Bundesdeutscher Fußballlehrer. Der hat mal gegenüber Zeit gesagt, Zitat, es ist ein schnelllebiges, knallhartes, manchmal brutales Geschäft. Wer zweimal gescheitert ist, kommt schwer wieder rein. Und damit meinte eben in den Profi-Fußball-Trainer-Bereich. Wird man denn darauf auch vorbereitet im Rahmen der Ausbildung, dass man auch mit Phasen der Arbeitslosigkeit umgehen muss, dass man vielleicht auch mit Geldsorgen umgehen muss? Denn im Gegensatz zu ehemaligen Spielern, die vielleicht sich etwas gespart haben aus ihrer Profizeit, ist es ja bei vielen Quereinsteigern in den Trainerberuf nicht mehr der Fall.
Ja, also was jetzt die finanziellen Dinge angeht, nee, das wird nicht thematisiert. Aber was natürlich thematisiert ist, was machst du, wenn du ohne Betätigung bist gerade? Also welche Möglichkeiten hast du, im Geschäft zu bleiben, im Gespräch zu bleiben? Was sind vielleicht auch No-Goes? Also dich vielleicht auf die Tribüne zu setzen, mit einem bekannten Gesicht bei einem Trainer, der vielleicht gerade wackelt. Ist das so die feine Art, um dich ins Gespräch zu bringen? Vielleicht eher nicht. Oder ja, also das Thema ist Netzwerk. Netzwerk ist das A und O. Es ist ja auch das Außergewöhnliche in diesem Beruf. Du bewirbst dich ja nicht klassisch, sondern irgendwer muss ja die Idee haben, dass du der Richtige sein könntest für den Verein. Ja, und da gilt es eben Netzwerk. Also ganz platt gesagt, kennste keinen, kriegste keinen Job. Ja, das ist im Prinzip so. Also entweder du oder dein Berater. Ja, man muss sich ins Gespräch bringen. Muss man sich ins Gespräch bringen? Das ist auch immer ein sehr zweischneidiges Schwert. Schwierig, schwierig, schwierig. Also für mich ja auch neu diese Situation. Aber es ist wichtig, Leute zu kennen und dein Netzwerk auch zu pflegen. Das ist schon sehr, sehr wichtig.
Hast du denn auch einen eigenen Berater?
Ja, genau. Wir machen das über den Berater von Torsten. Das lief quasi so gemeinsam.
Und ist das heutzutage dann auch so der Standard, dass eigentlich auch im Grunde jeder Fußballlehrer in Deutschland sich selbst nochmal beraten lässt, jemanden hat, der für ihn quasi immer mal wieder Klinken putzt und die Ohren aufstellt, Angebote einholt, vielleicht auch mal initiativ einen Anruf tätigt?
Ich würde sagen, die meisten, gerade im Profibereich, haben einen. Ich weiß jetzt aber auch nicht explizit, ob es welche gibt, die keinen haben. Viele von den Trainern sind ja nun mal auch welche, die eine Profi-Karriere hinter sich haben und während der Profi-Karriere eben auch schon Berater hatten. Aber so Trainer wie Julian Nagelsmann oder Domenico Tedesco und nur die beiden oder Florian Kohfeldt werden ja immer mehr, die jetzt keine Profi-Karriere hinter sich hatten. Ich glaube, irgendwann ist das dann in dem Geschäft so, da brauchst du einfach jemanden auch, der das dein rechtlich-vertraglich für dich regelt. Das sind ja dann irgendwann Dimensionen oder Verträge, woher sollst du dich damit auskennen, wenn du da vorher in den Dimensionen keine Erfahrung hattest. Darum glaube ich, dass es normal ist, dass jemand da einen hat, nicht nur um Klinken zu putzen, sondern einfach um gut beraten zu sein, einfach um keinen Fehler zu machen.
Sorry, das möchte ich noch mal kurz unterstreichen, weil da gibt es ja auch mittlerweile auch dieses Beraterberufsbild hat sich ja aufgespalten. Wir reden ja immer davon, dass es immer mehr Trainerstellen gibt, aber es gibt ja auch immer mehr Beraterstellen. Es gibt ja Medienberater mittlerweile, es gibt ja Leute, die das rein rechtlich machen und ich glaube, da ist es auch ganz interessant zu sehen. Da hat halt nicht jeder von jeder Sorte Berater etwas.
Das stimmt. Und gleichzeitig ist dieses ins Gespräch bringen, ist ja heutzutage nicht mehr nur, ich setze mich mit jemandem Bekannten auf eine Tribüne, was man vielleicht nicht tun sollte, wenn gerade ein Trainerstuhl wackelt in der Nähe und dieses Gespräch ins Gespräch bringen ist jetzt auch nicht nur, dass man sich irgendwie versucht, in Fußball-Talkshows zu setzen, sondern es gibt ja auch noch andere Möglichkeiten. Ich glaube, Tobi und ich, wir sind ganz gute Beispiele dafür, wie wir, also mein Netzwerk zumindest, Tobi, ich weiß nicht, wie es bei dir ist, beruht im Wesentlichen darauf, dass ich irgendwann über Twitter, über die Social-Media-Kanäle ganz viele Leute kennengelernt habe. Und dann, ich finde immer jemanden, der jemanden kennt, der jemanden kennt. Ich suche nach einem perfekten Gast für dieses Tribünengespräch. Dann frage ich Stefan Rommel. Herzliche Grüße an der Stelle. Vielen, vielen Dank. Er hat mich auf dich gebracht, Björn. Hat gesagt, frag doch mal bei Darmstadt, das könnte sehr gut passen. Und er hat dich wahrscheinlich irgendwann mal in seiner Tätigkeit als Journalist erlebt. Und gleichzeitig sehe ich aber, dass sehr, sehr wenige Trainer in sozialen Netzwerken aktiv sind. Ich rede jetzt gar nicht von Bundesliga- und Zweitligatrainern. Da kann ich das sehr gut nachvollziehen, warum dann auch ein Julian Nagelsmann das irgendwann zum Beispiel zurückgefahren hat. Aber von Trainern, Tobi, würde mir jetzt nur Christian Wück einfallen, der bei Twitter immer noch immer mal wieder etwas sagt, aber auch sehr, sehr wenige, sehr, sehr viel weniger intensiv als noch vor ein paar Jahren.
Ich glaube, dass das noch zu früh ist ein bisschen. Also wie ich die Fußballwelt jetzt kennengelernt habe, sind die Leute, die Entscheidungsträger an den Vereinen, gerade in Vereinen mit noch einer Vereinstruktur und einem Präsidenten, sind ältere Leute. Also gar nicht, gar nicht ab… Die Trainer sind jünger, aber die Leute, die darüber entscheiden, wer ihnen einen Job gibt, sind älter.
Ach so, und deswegen bringt das noch nichts im…
Ich habe ganz viele meiner journalistischen Aufträge darüber, dass ich irgendjemanden auf Twitter kennengelernt habe. Aber das ist ja im Trainerbereich nicht schwieriger, weil da ist ja niemand auf Twitter, auch auf der höheren Ebene. Aber auch das ändert sich langsam. Also ich habe auch mittlerweile gerade auf der Ebene, jetzt nicht Trainer-Ebene, aber auf der Ebene des Scoutings. Also ich kenne ganz viele Scouts mittlerweile über das Internet, dass man sich halt da so kennengelernt hat. Da gibt es auch Wege der Vernetzung. Und das ist glaube ich auch eine Sache, die sich natürlich dann auch ändert, wenn sich die Leute, die in den Vereinen die Jobs vergeben, wenn die sich verändern.
Ja, okay, guter Punkt. Dadurch, dass diejenigen, die dir den Job geben, noch nicht so aktiv sind in den Netzwerken, kann man da zwar Öffentlichkeit für sich gewinnen, aber vielleicht nicht bei den richtigen Leuten. Wie siehst du das, den Umgang mit sozialen Netzwerken auch eben zum Ziel, das zu tun, wofür sie ursprünglich mal da waren, nämlich sich ein Netzwerk aufzubauen, Björn?
Schwierig, ja, weiß ich. Ich kenne auch wenige Trainer, die sich jetzt explizit so äußern, wie man das jetzt auch mittlerweile von Spielern kennt, die das ja quasi täglich, minütlich machen.
So muss es ja auch gar nicht sein.
Nee, ja, der Mehrwert, der Mehrwert für mich als Trainer stellt sich mir dann jetzt gerade noch. Wen sollte ich kennenlernen? Also wenn es jetzt nur darum geht, irgendwie einen Benefit für einen Job dafür zu gewinnen, welchen Mehrwert hätte ich davon? Der wird sich mir gerade noch nicht erschließen, weil vielleicht eben die Berufsgruppe dann auch noch nicht aktiv ist und weil man vielleicht auch so in einem geschlossenen Kreis irgendwie auch bleiben möchte noch. Also wenn ich jetzt, weiß ich nicht, Trainer XY dort kontaktiere, können das ja auch andere mitlesen.
Gut, da brauchst du dann eine Social Media Schulung erst noch, dass wir dir sagen, wie man das macht, sodass das die Leute nicht lesen können. Vielleicht wird es in dem Punkt dann aber relevanter, wo es auch die Spieler für sich entdeckt haben. Also natürlich viel von dem, was Spieler in sozialen Netzwerken machen, das macht die Welt jetzt nicht besser, macht sie aber vielleicht auch nicht schlechter. Das ist so Teilhaben am Privatleben, ohne dass man vielleicht danach gefragt hätte, aber man muss ihnen ja nicht folgen. Aber die sozialen Netzwerke haben schon eine große Funktion, wenn es darum geht, wie sie die Mechanismen ausgehebelt haben, wie man mit einer großen Öffentlichkeit kommunizieren kann. Früher konntest du das nur über die Medien. Und wenn die Medien deinen Halbsatz, der das Zitat noch abgefangen hat, nicht mitdrucken, dann warst du aufgeschmissen. Heute hat man über die sozialen Netzwerke selbst die Möglichkeit, die Öffentlichkeit oder die interessierte Öffentlichkeit zu erreichen und kann da so ein bisschen in eine Abkürzung gehen, was auch viele Spiele für sich genutzt haben. Ein ganz tolles Beispiel dafür war, nach der WM 2014 gab es ein Video, auf dem man Bastian Schweinsteiger einen Schmähgesang in Richtung Borussia Dortmund hat singen hören und das rund in die Berichte hinein, dass er mit Kevin Großkreutz sich sehr gut angefreundet habe während dieses WM-Turniers. Als es gerade so anfing hoch zu kochen und die ersten Skandalschlagzeilen und droht jetzt der große Zoff und man hatte schon wieder den Eindruck, man hat es damit mit Beziehungsproblemen zu tun in der Berichterstattung, mitten in diese Zeit hinein, hat er ein Video gepostet auf Facebook und auf Instagram, wo er kurz gesagt hat, hat es eingeordnet hat und dann gesagt hat, Warnfehler, es tut mir leid und gerade an dich Kevin, du warst damit sowieso überhaupt nicht gemeint und Kevin Großkreutz hat bei Instagram drunter geschrieben, du, alles easy. Ist okay, jeder macht mal Fehler, alles gut. Und das Thema war tot. Und das ging nur, weil die beiden diese Plattform für sich selbst hatten. Ja, ich weiß nur deshalb noch, was Felix Maggert gerade beruflich macht, weil ich ihm auf Facebook folge. Du lachst Tobi, aber er nutzt es ja auch so auf eine eigene Art, das sind immer sehr wohlformulierte Zeilen, ich lese das auch ganz gern, ist jetzt nicht so, wie du oder ich wahrscheinlich Social Media machen würden, aber so muss es ja auch nicht gemacht werden. Vielleicht aber auch eine Frage der Zeit, da hat Tobi vielleicht auch recht. Schoss es mir so ein bisschen durch den Kopf, warum man das eigentlich nicht auch mehr für sich nutzt als Netzwerk. So, was hast du denn beim DFB dann eigentlich gemacht und wie kamst du dann zu Darmstadt 98, Björn? Wir sind ja eigentlich immer noch gar nicht durch.
Also, beim DFB war ich zunächst schimpfte sich das wissenschaftlicher Mitarbeiter in der Fußballlehrerausbildung.
Oh, Hiwi, sehr schön.
Klingt jetzt wissenschaftlicher Mitarbeiter, nicht Hiwi.
Ja, okay, stimmt, das ist recht, ja genau.
Also, war Teil des Dozententeams und war im Prinzip Ansprechpartner für die Teilnehmer, für gewisse Themen, für Vorträge, die ich auch gehalten habe. Also sprich, die Teilnehmer müssen dort sehr viel selber leisten, sehr viel selber erstellen, auch EDV-technisch, also PowerPoint-technischer Art, müssen Hausarbeiten schreiben. Darin habe ich sie geschult, war oft in Vertretung für den Frank Wormuth, der da noch Lehrgangsleiter war, wenn er mit der U20 unterwegs war, Themen übernommen. Also eben auch Vorträge gehalten zu bestimmten Themen und eben auch dafür zuständig, eben neue Themen auch zu entdecken. Also was gibt es Neues in der Spielanalyse, gibt es neue Software, gibt es neue Dinge, die es ja mittlerweile fast jedes Jahr gibt, die wir den Teilnehmern vorstellen können. Wie sieht es aus mit Tracking-Daten, also mit Opta zusammengearbeitet, dem Datenlieferer der ersten und zweiten Liga. Und so eben sowohl vor der Gruppe gearbeitet, wie eben auch normale Office-Arbeit. Und darüber dann eben auch noch, weil ich eben auch verspürt habe, mir fehlt dieses auf dem Platz zu stehen. Mich dafür ja quasi eingesetzt habe, auch bei einer Jugendnationalmannschaft mit im Boot zu sein. Und dann war ich das letzte Mal eben auch noch U19-Co-Trainer bei dem Frank Kramer, mit dem ich zusammen den Fußballlehrer auch gemacht habe. Da sind wir wieder bei Netzwerk. Also ich habe zusammen den Fußballlehrer gemacht. Er war dann U-Trainer und ich war dann mit dem Trainerteam auch. Ja und erneutes Thema Netzwerk. Der Torsten Frings hat dann einen Lehrgang gemacht, während ich beim DFB gearbeitet habe. Und wenn du dann dort arbeitest und 24 Teilnehmer dort jedes Jahr über zehn Monate begleitest, dann ist das natürlich ein Netzwerk, was du dir aufbaust. Das sind potenziell 24 potenzielle Bundesligatrainer oder Trainer, die im höchsten Bereich arbeiten. Und mit dem Torsten, ja wir haben uns irgendwie im Lehrgang gut verstanden. Der Kontakt ist nie abgerissen. Und als er dann dort Trainer wurde, habe ich ihm auch gleich bei WhatsApp gratuliert. Super, freue mich für dich. Und irgendwann kam er dann auch auf die Idee, mich zu fragen, ob ich nicht Lust hätte, seinen Co-Trainer zu werden. Und so ging das dann so seinen Gang. Und dann ging das auch ganz, ganz fix. Und da war ich dem DFB auch sehr dankbar, dass sie mich da eben auch rausgelassen haben aus der Tätigkeit und mir die Möglichkeit gegeben haben, das wahrzunehmen, eben in diesem höchsten Bereich tätig zu sein.
Und dann kamst du eben zu Darmstadt 98 in dieser Rückrunde der Erstligasaison und warst dann im Grunde ein Jahr zusammen eben mit dem ganzen Trainerteam von Torsten Frings dort tätig. Was hat dich denn die Zeit im Verein gelehrt?
Ich kann es nur mit Wahnsinn beschreiben. Gerade das erste halbe Jahr, erste Liga noch, im größten Business dabei zu sein, was du vorher jahrelang selber nur aus dem Fernsehen oder von der Tribüne aus erlebt hast, so standst du hautnah neben den Protagonisten, hast eingewirkt auf eben Bundesliga. Und da musste ich mich auch das eine oder andere mal kneifen, wenn man dann in einer Allianzarena sitzt und ach, hier der Xavier Alonso, der macht sich jetzt warm, alles klar. Also es war beeindruckend, was ich gelernt habe, ist, dass die Überschriften der Inhalte nicht so anders sind, was wir gerade schon mal hatten. Es ist Profibereich, es ist allerhöchster Bereich, aber die Arbeit ist nicht ganz anders, sondern das Drumherum ist anders, das Medienaufkommen ist anders, das wie du beäugt wirst ist anders. Du wirst selber vielleicht ein bisschen vorsichtiger im Umgang mit den Spielern. Ich glaube, Torsten und ich sind eher Typen, die ziemlich nah an der Mannschaft sind, aber da musste ich auch, denke ich, manchmal so einen Schritt zurück machen, nicht zu viel Nähe zulassen, auch den nötigen Respekt mir erarbeiten, weil ich natürlich nicht die Profikarriere hatte. Und ja, dort einfach auch von Torsten viel gelernt habe, weil er in dem großen Business schon so lange dabei ist, was die Arbeit mit dem Großen und Ganzen angeht, aber eben auch viel gelernt habe, im Umgang, also Trainerteam zusammen Dinge erarbeiten, zusammen Dinge diskutieren, Kaderplanung voranzutreiben, Spieler-Scouting ganz detailliert anzugehen, Spielvorbereitung, Gegneranalysen auf allerhöchstem Niveau, sehr gewissenhaft dann den Spielern eben auch dazu legen. Das war unfassbar lehrreich und ja, Blut geleckt und freue mich auf die nächste Aufgabe schon.
Macht es denn mehr Spaß, den FC Bayern vorzubereiten in der Spielanalyse beim kommenden Gegner oder plakatives Beispiel Erzgebirge Aue, weil es einem vielleicht etwas weniger Angst macht von dem, was man da so defensiv auf den Platz bringen muss?
Bayern macht insofern mehr Spaß, weil du natürlich die Weltklassisspieler alle kennst. Es ist insofern vielleicht sogar die größte Herausforderung der Mannschaft, Dinge aufzuzeigen, wie sie vielleicht doch Möglichkeiten haben, gegen Bayern zu bestehen. Wir hätten in der Allianz Arena beinahe einen Punkt mitgenommen. Altin Top hat einen Elfmeter verschossen, das wäre das 1-1 gewesen. Natürlich sind große Namen interessant, aber das Handwerkszeug bleibt das gleiche. Es gilt aufzuzeigen, wie der Gegner in Offensive und Defensive spielt. Was gibt es für Muster, die man erkennen kann? Wie spielen wir dagegen? Welche Möglichkeiten und Räume ergeben sich für uns? Das ist eigentlich immer die gleiche Schablone.
Was, wenn man sich das Buch von Tobi durchliest und auch wenn man ein bisschen im Thema ist, auch weiß, warum z.B. Pep Guardiola so wenig Interviews geben wollte beim FC Bayern usw. und so fort, dann merkt man, Zeit ist somit das höchste Gut für einen Fußballtrainer. Wie würdest du denn sagen, hat sich die Zeit von Torsten Frings und dir bei Darmstadt 98 aufgeteilt auf die unterschiedlichen Tätigkeitsbereiche, also Trainingsvorbereitung, aktuelles Training, Leitung, Scouting, Medienarbeit und alles, was es da noch gibt?
Also Zeit ist wirklich so ein Faktor, also das Abschalten. Das Abschalten ist schwieriger. Irgendwie ist es 24-7, weil selbst wenn du dann Tschüss sagst aus dem Stadion und selbst dann liegst du abends im Bett und du schreibst dir noch eine WhatsApp-Nachricht, weil dir irgendwie was noch eingefallen ist, also du bist irgendwie mit dem Kopf dann doch dabei. Und das ist jetzt aber auch, will ich gar nicht sagen, dass es ein negativer Stress ist, sondern ich habe es als positiven Stress empfohlen. Klar gibt es auch Wochen, wo es negativ ist, wenn es irgendwie von Misserfolg geprägt ist, aber es ist ein positiver Stress. Es macht einfach unfassbar viel Spaß, weil du selbst weißt, wie du einwirken kannst. Und natürlich ist Torstens Bereich in der Medienarbeit größer wie meiner. Der ist sehr gering gewesen. Das waren mal einzelne Interviews, die ich aber auch gerne gemacht habe, weil es mir Spaß gemacht hat. Aber natürlich ist der Cheftrainer das Gesicht des Vereins und er hat da viel mehr mit zu tun. Und ansonsten bereitet man im Training Dinge gemeinsam vor. Das macht man im Prinzip gemeinsam, diskutiert gemeinsam. Mein Part war dann eher konkret im Detail die Gegnervorbereitung, Spielnachbereitung.
Wie lange braucht man da so?
Also wir haben uns immer das letzte Heimspiel und das letzte Auswärtsspiel des Gegners angeschaut. Und so ein Spiel zerlegst du schon über das. Also ein Spiel kann schon mal so drei Stunden in Anspruch nehmen, weil du spultst vor, du spultst zurück, du schneidest. Das habe ich jetzt nicht alleine gemacht. Der Videoanalyst, der Kai Peter Schmitz, der hat da auch sehr stark eingewirkt. Aber man versucht den Gegner schon richtig auseinanderzunehmen bei der Gegnervorbereitung, um dass dir da auch nichts durch die Lappen geht. Weil es natürlich auch etwas ist, wo du das Vertrauen der Spieler gewinnen oder eben auch verlieren kannst. Das, was du ihnen, wenn du denen dreimal irgendwas erzählst, was nicht eintritt, dann verlieren die natürlich das Vertrauen. Das ist natürlich klar. Und deswegen willst du da keinen Fehler machen. Und auch Standardsituationen, die schaust du dir vor, zurück, schaust du dir zigmal an, wie sind Laufwege, wird geblockt, wer kommt. Das waren jetzt die ersten Elf der letzten zwei Spiele. Aber was sind potenzielle andere? Was ist eine potenzielle andere Startaufstellung? Welche Besonderheiten haben die Spieler? Und dann Zusammenarbeit mit den Scouts, die wir eben auch haben, die die Spiele angeschaut haben, die Einzelanalysen von den Spielern gemacht haben. Da macht man dann noch Sitzungen explizit und da bekommen die Spieler auch nochmal detaillierte Infos über ihren Gegenspieler und Eigenheiten.
Ich glaube, wir alle drei in der Runde haben das gemeinsam, dass wir schon häufiger versucht haben, Fußballspiele zu analysieren. Jeder so auf seinem eigenen Level, ich ganz sicher unter euch, anderen beiden. Deswegen würde mich umso mehr interessieren. Tobi, fang du mal an. Was machst denn du, wenn du mal einen schlechten Tag hast? Mir geht es immer wieder so, dass ich Spiele gucke und ich konzentriere mich und ich versuche, Dinge zu sehen. Man muss ja einfach geistig sehr frisch sein, um Dinge zu erkennen. Dann gibt es wiederum Tage, da schaue ich Spiele und mir fallen zig Sachen auf. Was machst du denn, wenn du mal das Gefühl hast, heute habe ich nicht den Spielanalyse Tobi mit dabei? Oder gibt es das gar nicht bei dir, Maschine?
Doch, das gibt es. Richtig schlechte Tage gibt es selten nur noch, weil du irgendwann so viele Routine hast, in bestimmten Sachen zu erkennen, dass die gehen auch, wenn du im Halbschlaf bist. Ob die Viererkette gut verschiebt, erkenne ich mittlerweile. Das habe ich so drin. Aber es gibt natürlich ein paar Workarounds, ein paar Basics, an denen du dich aufhängen kannst. Dann denkst du dir, ich habe den Luxus, dass ich keine Mannschaft vorbereiten muss. Das ist doch ein riesiger Unterschied. Wenn ich ein Detail übersehe, dann macht das niemand etwas. Dann hat der Leser nach einem Detail vielleicht weniger. Wenn dann der Trainer etwas übersieht, dann kann es schon mal passieren, dass man dann doch dreieinundvierzig verliert, wenn man dieses Detail im Taktik des Gegners übersehen hat. Aber gerade bei meiner Arbeit, das kennst du auch, darüber reden wir auch oft. Es gibt viele Workarounds mit Statistiken zum Beispiel. Wenn du dann noch mal reinguckst, wo die Pässe hingegangen sind, dann stellst du fest, die haben hundert Pässe mehr nach links als nach rechts gespielt, dann guckst du da noch mal drauf zum Beispiel. Also da gibt es schon so Fallschirme.
Wie ist das bei dir, Björn?
Ja, so Tage gibt es da zwei Möglichkeiten, sich durchzubeißen und hoffen, dass man nichts übersieht. Oder auch einfach mal ein Laptop zuklappen und jetzt geht einfach mal gar nichts mehr. Wir haben natürlich sechs oder sogar acht Augenprinzip. Also nicht nur ich habe mir die Spiele angeschaut, sondern auch unser Videoanalyst, der Karl-Peter Schmitz. Dann haben wir die Scouts noch gehabt, die drüber geschaut haben. Und Torsten hat sich die Spiele natürlich auch angeschaut. Vielleicht nicht im Detail vor und zurück, aber dass er auf jeden Fall einen krassen Eindruck bekommt von dem, was uns da erwartet. Das heißt, du hast dann auch dich zusammengesetzt und dich ergänzt. Also Szenen, die ich vielleicht gar nicht hatte, hatte dann jemand anders parat und so ergibt das dann ein rundes Bild. Aber für mich war natürlich dann schon, weil ich der Vortragende war vor der Mannschaft, also eben auch derjenige, der das präsentiert hat, natürlich willst du da nicht derjenige sein, der irgendeinen Mist verzapft. Darum war es schon immer so, dass man das gewissenhaft macht. Das war jetzt Gegnervorbereitung zum Thema Zeitdruck noch mal, eigenes Spiel. Das willst du natürlich irgendwie zeitnah machen. Also da ist die eine oder andere Busfahrt, also das Spiel ist vorbei, was weiß ich, spielst du jetzt beim Thema Erzwege auf, fährst noch stundenlang zurück bis nachts zuhause. Und vielleicht willst du am nächsten Tag schon direkt die Analyse. Dann ist es auch nicht mit Beine hochlegen getan. Es ist groggy, aber dann machst du irgendwie in der Nacht noch die Analyse fertig, damit du da am nächsten Tag direkten Haken hinter machen kannst. Also das ist dann schon immer zeitintensiv. Und die Arbeit wird so gemacht, wie sie halt dann anfällt.
Das ist ein sehr, sehr spannendes Thema, was ich auch mit vielen Jugendtrainern, gerade von Spielverlagerung.de, sind ja jetzt auch einige in den Trainerbereich, auch von spielverlagerung.com. Und da ist so ein heißes Thema immer Schlafmangel. Ja, das klingt jetzt aber witzig, aber die kommen in den Profibereich gerade quasi ran und erleben genau das, dass dann sehr viel gearbeitet werden muss, dass auch sehr viel dann nachts noch nach dem Spiel zu verstemmen, damit am nächsten Morgen fertig ist. Und wie geht man damit um tatsächlich, trotz weniger Schlaf, als man gewohnt ist, Leistung abzuliefern? Und das ist, glaube ich, auch so ein Ding, was für Trainer auch ganz wichtig ist, weil halt Zeit so ein gewichtiger Faktor ist. Und weil du halt dann teilweise keine Zeit hast, einfach. Weil gerade sehr großartiges Beispiel. Du spielst Donnerstag und dann wieder Sonntag und dann muss natürlich Freitag die Analyse fertig sein, weil wenn du erst Samstag anfängst, dann das nächste Spiel vorzubereiten, das ist zu spät. Das ist halt brutal.
Ja, da muss ich genau zugeben, dass ich mir da auch schon mal so dachte, diesen Rhythmus hatte ich nicht mit Darmstadt, mit drei Spielen, vielleicht mal wenn wir im Pokalspiel waren, aber wir sind eigentlich in der ersten Runde rausgeflogen, deswegen kam das nicht so häufig vor. Also, die Trainer, die das auf allerhöchstem Niveau jahrelang machen, diesen Rhythmus montags, mittwochs, samstags, Wahnsinn, wie staccatomäßig die Dinge abarbeiten müssen, das stelle ich mir auch wahnsinnig vor. Da musst du für dich Tools finden, wie du halt mit Stress umgehst. Stressregulation, das ist auch Thema in der Fußballlehrerausbildung. Was kannst du da machen? Da muss jeder was für sich finden, aber da kannst du dir sicherlich auch immer wieder Hilfe holen, Coaches oder Psychologen, die dir da Dinge mit an die Hand geben. Du musst irgendwann runterfahren, weil sonst ist es schon krass. Die Leute, die dann wie Thomas Duchel dann mal ein Jahr an das Sabbatical nehmen, das ist ja auch immer ein bisschen in Mode gekommen, aber kann das schon verstehen, wenn du so gerade als Cheftrainer immer im Fokus stehst und täglich da so abreißen musst.
Ja, das ist das Thema. Es ist vor allem, glaube ich, sehr schlau, weil wenn man auch sagt, ich gehe in ein Sabbatical, dann ist es klar, das hat einen Endpunkt. Sprich, alle Leute, die einen Trainer suchen, hört mal genau her, ich komme irgendwann wieder zurück. Und gleichzeitig heißt ein Sabbatical ja auch nicht zwölf Monate Malle, sondern man hat Zeit für Praktika, für Weiterbildung, auch fürs Durchschnaufen, fürs Schlaf nachholen und so weiter. Aber ich glaube, deswegen werden wir das immer häufiger erleben, dass Trainer das machen. Aber wenn du jetzt schon Stress ansprichst, wenn Tobi schon Schlafmangel anspricht, dann lass uns auch zumindest kurz darüber sprechen, dass die Zeit bei Darmstadt 98 ja auch vorbei ging in der zweiten Liga dann. Das war nach einem Spiel gegen Erzgebirge Aue. Stand Darmstadt 98 auf dem 16. Tabellenplatz der zweiten Liga. Man kam eben aus der ersten Liga. Und dann war die Zeit von Torsten Frings und damit zwangsläufig – auch deine Zeit – bei Darmstadt 98 vorbei. Wie hast du deine erste Trainerentlassung erlebt? Verzeih mir die, wie fühlen sie sich, Frage an der Stelle.
Also zum Thema Torsten Freigestellt und ich mit. Also das war für uns beide klar, dass wir da als Team weitergehen. Und das wusste der Verein auch, dass wir beide da im Tandem im Prinzip sind. Von daher war das für mich nicht überraschend, wenn Torsten geht, dass ich dann mitfreigestellt werde. Es kam dann doch ein bisschen überraschend, weil es stand noch ein Spiel an gegen Kräuter Fürth vor der Winterpause. Da hätten wir schon gedacht, dass wir das noch bekommen. Wenn das auch verloren gegangen wäre, dann hätte man ja selber natürlich auch schon darüber nachgedacht, dass es dann zu diesem Szenario hätte kommen können. Also das ging dann doch schnell. Und ja, wie fühlt man sich? Es ist nie ein schönes Gefühl, wenn man gegangen wird. So ist es ja, weil man für sich einfach alles reinlegt, 100 Prozent gibt. Ich will gar nicht sagen, dass man 100 Prozent alles richtig macht. Wer macht das schon? Und dennoch war es jetzt aber auch Teil des Geschäfts. Auch wenn das für mich das erste Mal war, war es für mich klar, dass das irgendwann so kommt. Ich glaube, ich bin jemand, der sich auf so Situationen gut einstellen kann. Torsten hat dann auch zu mir gesagt, du wirst so drei Phasen erleben, jetzt erst mal bist du richtig, richtig enttäuscht, weil er es bei Bremenheim auch erlebt hat, du wirst richtig enttäuscht sein. Dann kommt eine Phase, genieß es einfach, versuche in eine Phase zu kommen, wo du einfach abschaltest. Und jetzt ist so eine Phase schon länger da, wo man einfach wieder mit den Hufen scharrt und einfach wieder Bock hat einzusteigen. Und da hat er absolut recht mit gehabt.
Thematisiert man so etwas, oder ist das ein Damoklesschwert, was wie so ein unausgesprochener Elefant im Raum bei vielen Trainerbesprechungen einfach mit dabei ist, aber man will ja jetzt auch nicht drüber sprechen? Was meint ihr, wenn wir verlieren, sind wir dann am nächsten Montag noch hier?
Weniger solche Szenarien, nicht solche Wenn-Dann-Sachen, sondern das wird schon thematisiert. Also da kann ich es auch wieder nur von Torsten sprechen, der da sehr feines Gefühl für hat, weil er sehr lange in den Geschäften dabei ist, sowohl von Spielerseite als Kapitän bei Werder Bremen, das Strömung mitbekommen hat und selber weiß, dass er ein Gefühl dafür hat und wir das natürlich auch diskutiert haben. Sicher bist du ja nie von Vereinsseite, kam da eher immer ein Veto, wenn solche Dinge in der Presse gefragt wurden. Deswegen ist es so gekommen, wie es gekommen ist. Aber klar wird das auch diskutiert, das wird nicht totgeschwiegen, das wird ganz normal darüber gesprochen.
Und wie muss ich mir das dann vorstellen? Gang zum Arbeitsamt, hallo, guten Tag, ich wurde gekündigt, was haben Sie bisher gemacht, Fußballlehrer? Okay, wir bieten in einer Umschulung zum Landschaftsgärtner an.
Ja, also den Gang habe ich wirklich gemacht. Also erstmal, eine Freistellung ist ja keine Kündigung. Also von daher, der Vertrag lief erstmal formal bis zum Ende der Saison weiter. Und dennoch musste man ja frühzeitig, damit du da Fristen einhältst, beim Arbeitsamt vorstellig werden, um im Falle einer eben Nicht-Beschäftigung dann eben dich auch offiziell arbeitslos melden zu können. Und das Gespräch war eigentlich ganz interessant, weil beim Arbeitsamt, wenn man sich dort meldet, man dazu verpflichtet ist, sich 20 Bewerbungen oder den Versuch einer Wiedereingliederung irgendwie nachweisen muss. Und dann musste ich erläutern, dass es kontraproduktiv wäre in diesem Job.
Lieber Herr FC Bayern, ich bewerbe mich initiativ.
Und die nette Dame hatte von Fußball gar keine Ahnung, war aber wirklich total nett und war sehr interessiert. Ich habe ihr das dann so erklärt und dann hat sie auch den Link gefunden, dass es vielleicht ähnlich ist wie bei Vorständen oder so, dass diese klassische Bewerbung da wegfällt.
Ok, dir wurde keine Umschulung zum Landschaftsgärtner angeboten?
Nein, mir wurde nichts angeboten.
Ok, Tobi, du hast ja ganz, ganz verschiedene Tränebiografien in deinem Buch Zeit der Strategen analysiert. Wo würdest du da denn jetzt Björn Müller einordnen zwischen José Mourinho und Pep Guardiola? Wo steht seine Trainerbiografie?
Er würde im Buch wahrscheinlich eher später vorkommen. Also im hinteren Teil des Buchs, wo es ja dann um deutsche Trainer geht und auch um Trainer, die nicht diese klassische Weltklassikspieler oder Spieler auf grobem Niveau, auf allerhöchstem Niveau und dann zum Trainer umfunktioniert werden. Diese klassische Biografie hat er nicht, sondern halt dann eher in diese Richtung Tuchel Nagelsmann aus dem Jugendbereich heraus, aus der Nachwuchsbereich heraus nach oben gekommen. Was ja ein ganz legitimer Weg mittlerweile ist, den es aber so vor 20 Jahren nicht gab, das haben wir auch schon gesagt.
Wer waren denn da so diejenigen, die diesen Weg geebnet haben? Irgendjemand muss ja als Erster im deutschen Profifußball gegangen sein.
Es gab natürlich da verschiedene Trainer, die aus dem Jugendbereich hochgekommen sind, die aber teilweise schon wieder vergessen wurden. Michael Önding zum Beispiel, der ja auch lange Zeit in der Jugendarbeit gearbeitet hat. Der erste, wo man sagen muss, dass es wirklich geklappt hat, von der U19 in Mainz damals dann wirklich zum Cheftrainer und mittlerweile auch angekommen bei Paris Stade de Jumeur, also einem wirklichen Weltclub. Das war Thomas Tuchel, der dann auch so einen Hype einsetzen hat damals lassen, dass die Leute an den Hebeln in den Vereinen gemerkt haben, okay, wir schauen uns mal in der eigenen Jugendabteilung um, ob da nicht irgendein Trainer ist, den wir entwickeln und zum Chefcoach formen können. Was dann wieder ganz eigene Probleme mit sich bringt, aber das ist wieder ein anderes Thema.
Eine Ergänzung dazu, nicht nur, dass die Vereine im eigenen Jugendbereich mal schauen, sondern dass es durchaus eine Philosophie sein kann, ich entwickle mir meinen zukünftigen Cheftrainer im Jugendbereich. Das ist auch ein sehr interessantes Thema, inwieweit das planbar ist oder durchzusetzen ist, aber sicherlich für viele Vereine sehr interessant. Barcelona oder Real Madrid machen ja solche Dinge. Zidane war auch im Jugendbereich, Pep Guardiola war im Jugendbereich, Guti war jetzt U19-Trainer und war als Trainerkandidat bei Real. Also, ein interessantes Modell, sinnvoll in meinen Augen.
Andererseits ist dann auch wieder jetzt die Frage, dass es jetzt wieder ein Themenwechsel ist, da will ich gar nicht auch einsteigen. Es hat natürlich dann wieder Folgen im Jugendbereich, dass der Jugendbereich jetzt so ein bisschen zum Sprungbrett verkommen ist für Trainer, die in einen anderen Bereich wollen. Das hat dann natürlich wieder eine gewisse Auswirkung auf die Jugendarbeit auch. Das ist, was man ja auch beim DFB mittlerweile der Meinung ist, dass man vielleicht stärker wieder Leute bräuchte im Jugendbereich, die nur Jugendarbeit waren.
Das finde ich einen ganz wichtigen Punkt, weil du musst doch mit einem Jugendlichen ganz anders psychologisch umgehen und musst auch andere Fähigkeiten haben als Pädagoge als eben im Seniorenbereich dann.
Also wenn du jemanden findest, also Norbert Elgert, Schalke 04, U19-Trainer seit langen Jahren, ein Paradebeispiel dafür, der über Jahrzehnte so viel Talente rausgebracht hat und sich absolut der Jugendarbeit verschrien hat. Und wenn du dort nicht das als Sprungbrett siehst, sondern dich dort heimisch fühlst und da über Jahrzehnte auch alles durchlebst, dann wirst du da ja auch Experte für deinen Zweig. Aber das ist im Verein so. Der C-Jugendtrainer will gerne in die B-Jugend trainieren und der U17-Trainer will dann irgendwie U19-Trainer werden, weil natürlich größeres Renommee und vielleicht auch ein bisschen mehr Geld. Also gab auch mal so Überlegungen als Jugendkonzepte, dass man sagt, die C- und A-Jugendtrainer, die werden alle gleich bezahlt. Ganz transparent, jeder weiß. Somit ist das Streben danach vielleicht etwas höher zu kommen, auf monetärer Seite gar nicht so gegeben. Auch ein Punkt, den Vereine schon mal diskutiert haben.
Aber wird jetzt noch nicht praktiziert, oder?
Ich glaube, in den Niederlanden haben die mal sowas gemacht. Auf Flächendecken weiß ich jetzt auch nicht. Von deutschen Vereinen wüsste ich es jetzt nicht.
Wie viele Trainer im Nachwuchsbereich bei Profi-Vereinen sind denn eigentlich hauptamtliche Nachwuchstrainer?
So grob gesprochen. Mittlerweile würde ich sagen, dass fast jeder U19- und U17-Trainer hauptamtlich ist, also die beiden A- und B-Jugendtrainer. Bei größeren Vereinen vielleicht sogar der Co-Trainer. Teilweise geht es runter bis zur D-Jugend, dass die dort hauptamtlich sind. Da gibt es noch einige Vereine, der HSV weiß ich, die haben einen hauptamtlichen Techniktrainer. Dann gibt es den sportlichen Leiter. Also der Manuel Baum, bevor er Profitrainer wurde, war er jetzt nicht nur U23-Trainer, sondern er war quasi Nachwuchscheftrainer. Also quasi ist es so eine Coach-the-Coach-Modell. Also jemand, der die jungen Trainer noch führt und unterstützt und für sie da ist und keine Mannschaft hat, sondern sich quasi um das Coaching der Coaches kümmert, um sie im Verein tagtäglich weiterzuentwickeln. Das denke ich auch ein Berufszeug, der mehr kommt, der immer mehr kommen wird.
Ebert Lin macht das Ähnliches bei St. Pauli.
Ebert Lin, ja, richtig, genau. Also da gibt es schon einige Stellen. Also die A-Jugend-Stellen, U19-Stellen, U17-Stellen. Fast durchweg, fast durchweg mit Fußballlehrerlizenz besetzt auch und eben auch dementsprechend hauptamtlich.
So, dann können wir jetzt eigentlich die Frage aller Fragen stellen. Denn wie wird man denn jetzt eigentlich Fußballlehrer oder Fußballtrainer? Wir müssen ja nicht immer nur über den Profibereich reden. Es gibt ja auch eine ganz breite Basis, Björn.
Genau, also wenn wir uns diese Ausbildungsmöglichkeiten vorstellen, kann man sich eine Pyramide vorstellen, an deren Spitze der Fußballlehrer steht. Und dort drunter es verschiedene Lizenzstufen gibt. Also es gibt den Fußballlehrer an oberster Stelle, darunter die Trainer A-Lizenz, dann die DFB Elite Jugendlizenz, dann die Trainer B-Lizenz und die Trainer C-Lizenz. Das ist so eine Fünfstufigkeit.
Das ist auch typisch deutsch, dass es nicht A, B, C, D ist, Entschuldigung, sondern dass da mittendrin noch die Elite Jugendlizenz drin ist.
Ja, das ist genau. Das Ganze ist geregelt von der UEFA. Es gibt eine UEFA-Convention, da ist es Pro Level, A Level, B Level und dann eben C Level oder Grassroots. Der DFB ist da so ein bisschen eigen und hat das nochmal umstrukturiert. Hat auch mit DOSB-Richtlinien zu tun. Aber ja, ist typisch deutsch, kann man so sagen. Vorweg vielleicht einmal zur Struktur. Also es ist nicht nur alles der DFB, der das ausbildet. Der DFB ist der Dachverband und unter dem DFB gibt es 21 Fußball-Landesverbände, die den Spielbetrieb in den Bundesländern organisieren. Das sind insgesamt 25.000 Fußballvereine, die dem DFB angehören. Und noch eine beeindruckende Zahl sind 160.000 Männer- und Frauenmannschaften aller Altersklassen, die jährlich zum Spielbetrieb gemeldet sind. 160.000 Mannschaften, die müssen trainiert werden. Und das sind natürlich nicht 160.000 ausgebildete Trainer. Aber jeder, der dort auch im Amateurbereich seinem Hobby nachgeht als Trainer, der Papa, der seinen Sohn oder Mann trainiert, der hat Möglichkeiten, sich vorzubilden. Also einerseits im Internet, es gibt Rubriken beim DFB, Training, Training online nennt sich das, da kann ich ohne überhaupt irgendwo hinzugehen, mir vorgefertigte Trainingseinheiten runterladen. Wenn ich nun aber auch wirklich einen Ausbilder vor der Nase haben möchte, der mir was beibringt, dann gibt es sogenannte Kurzschulungen, die Vereine sich quasi buchen können. Es gibt das DFB-Mobil, also jeder Verband hat so einen kleinen Bus, der fährt durch die Lande, fährt in die Vereine, macht dort Schulungen. Also für jeden ist irgendwie was dabei, der, und das ist auch nicht hoch genug anzurechnen, der seinem Ehrenamt danach geht, weil was da an Stunden abgerackert wird, das kann die Politik alles gar nicht leisten. Das ist, da habe ich als Ausbilder in Hamburg, wenn du vornehmlich mit Trainern zu tun hattest, die wirklich Kinder- und Jugendmannschaft trainiert haben, den Hut, habe ich immer gesagt, der kann gar nicht so groß sein, den ich vor euch ziehe. Ihr nehmt euch jetzt zwei, drei Wochen Urlaub, das ist womöglich euer Jahresurlaub, damit ihr euer Hobby ein bisschen besser macht, damit ihr besseres Training für eure Kinder anbietet. Das ist erstaunlich, aber so startet häufig eine Karriere, dass du eine untere Lizenz machst und da auch schon dann ein, zwei, drei Wochen in einer Sportschule deines Landesverbandes bist, Prüfungen absolvieren musst, Training geben musst und da eben auch schon benotet wirst.
Was sind da so die Themen, die man beigebracht bekommt auf dieser untersten Stufe?
Das hängt ab von dem Profil, was du wählst. Also geht es in den Bereich Kindertraining. Wie gehe ich im allerjüngsten Bereich mit Bambini und F-Junior um? Wie sind die Kinder von einer Aufnahmefähigkeit strukturiert? Wie sollte das Training aussehen? Natürlich eher spielerisch. An jeder Stelle sollte ein Ball sein und nicht irgendwie, lauft euch mal fünf Runden ein. Das brauchen die nicht. Und dann gehst du alle Altersstufen durch. Wie gehe ich mit D- und C-Junior um? Thema Pubertät. Wie versuche ich darauf einzuwirken, dass die Kinder dem Sport erhalten bleiben? Und natürlich dann auch fußballerische Elemente, also individualtaktische Dinge, gruppentaktische Dinge, erste-mannschaftstaktische Sachen in den höheren Lizenzen. Also jede Altersstufe hat da seine Eigenheiten, wie sie auch einfach von der Psychologie her geführt werden. Und darauf geht man ein.
Also wird da auch Pädagogik mit einbezogen?
In ganz großem Maße. Pädagogik, Didaktik. Man könnte es Methodik nennen. Also wie strukturiere ich eine gute Trainingsstunde oder diese anderthalb Stunden, die ich auf dem Platz stehe, dass es einen roten Faden hat? Also Thema roter Faden. Dass das Aufwärmen abgestimmt ist mit dem ersten hinführenden Teil. Dass man irgendwie Schwerpunkte erkennt. Und wie kann ich das eben aufbauen, dass ich da ein gutes Training leite? Ja, ganz großer Teil.
Wie wichtig ist da die Leistungskomponente? Wenn man sich auf den Juniorenplätzen so ein bisschen rumtreibt, gerade – ich komme vom Land, da habe ich sehr viele Eindrücke gesammelt – da hat man alles mit dabei. Und meistens sehr, sehr viel Ehrgeiz, sowohl bei Zuschauern, was sich dann in Unmut gegen Schiedsrichter und Trainer äußert, aber auch bei Trainern selbst. Da hast du manchmal das Gefühl, du würdest Champions League spielen und nicht unterste Kreisklasse irgendwo in Unterfranken. Und das ist jetzt ganz mein persönliches Erfahrungserlebnis. Wird sowas auch thematisiert? Hat der DFB dazu eine Haltung zu dieser Balance zwischen Leistung? Und im Grunde geht es ja aber an der Basis erstmal um den Sport, um das Sporttreiben. Und das hat viel mit Spaß zu tun.
Ja, also ich habe den Trainern immer versucht zu vermitteln, welche Verantwortung sie auch haben. Also die Verantwortung darüber, ob sie einem Kind womöglich Spaß am lebenslangen Sport treiben, vermitteln oder so einen Mist dort irgendwie veranstalten, dass die Kinder nach Hause gehen und keine Lust mehr haben zum Fußball zu gehen und womöglich keine Lust mehr haben, in den Sportverein zu gehen. Also das war mir immer sehr wichtig. Ob das jetzt eine Haltung vom DFB ist? Ja, doch, auf jeden Fall. Da musste unterscheiden, bin ich jetzt in einem Leistungsbereich, wo ich teilweise auch aussiebe und Kindern auch sage, nein, du bist nicht mehr gut genug. Und das passiert ja schon sehr früh auch, in einem Alter von, weiß nicht, zehn, elf Jahren werden Kinder vielleicht nicht übernommen in die nächste Altersstufe. Das geht dann damit einher, wenn du im Leistungsfußball bist. Und wenn du das ganz hobbymäßig machst, dann musst du die Kinder da abholen, wo sie stehen. Wenn sie nicht zehnmal den Ball hochhalten können, dann musst du sie versuchen, dahin zu bringen, dass sie es vielleicht fünfmal können und vielleicht irgendwann mal zehnmal. Und wenn die Gruppe heterogen ist, dann versucht man, ein Training anzubieten, wo jeder gefordert wird, um sie dann in Gruppen einzuteilen. Und das wird absolut thematisiert in den unteren Lizenzstufen. Weil das eben auch die Probleme sind. Natürlich geht es immer um Sieg und Niederlage, aber es geht auch darum, die Kinder bei der Stange zu halten und dass sie womöglich alle dabei bleiben.
Es gibt ja auch schon auf dieser untersten Kinderebene interessante Unterschiede zwischen deutschen Fußball und jetzt zum Beispiel spanischen Fußball. Mir fällt gerade der Name nicht ein. Wie heißt die Spielform, die die Spanier machen, wo man, ich glaube, auf drei Tore spielt mit Kindern und in sehr kleinen Teams.
Nein, Rondos ist der die, der in der Mitte ist.
Du meinst, dass von Horst Wein entwickelte, also Entwicklung der Spielintelligenz nennt sich das, dass das Horst Wein, der verstorben ist, entwickelt. Ja, kleines Feld, drei Tore.
Genau, das wird auch nicht gezählt. Und die Kinder kommen dann aber, also jedes Kind kommt da in alle verschiedenen Situationen, die man hat in einem Fußballspiel, nämlich dass man offensiv denken muss, dass man defensiv denken muss. Und jedes Kind kommt auch an den Ball. Es ist nicht so, dass quasi nur die Besten und Schnellsten immer am Ball sind. Und da gibt es ja interessante Debatten darüber, warum nicht solche Übungen im Kinder- und Jugendbereich einsetzen. Oder auch Futsal ist dann quasi so die Hallendiskussion, die ähnlich dazu ist. Da sind die Deutschen, meinem Empfinden nach, noch sehr traditionell unterwegs. Habe ich da vielleicht nur einen eingeschränkten Blick?
Also von der Trainer-Ausbildung ist es so, dass man das absolut pusht und genau das fordert. Kleine Gruppen, viele Ballkontakte. Also schau dir ein D-Jugendspiel an. Das sind 10- bis 12-Jährige. Die spielen teilweise übers ganze Feld. Zum Glück ist das mittlerweile schon etwas verkleinert worden, das Feld. Aber da wird eine Spielverlagerung von den Trainern gefordert. Ich habe Trainer immer an die Mittellinie gestellt und sie sollten in die Hocke gehen. Und wenn du in der Mittellinie stehst und in die Hocke gehst, dann siehst du das Feld aus der Sicht und der Größe des Kindes. Und das Tor sieht plötzlich so weit weg aus, als wenn du das aus deiner Erwachsenenperspektive siehst. Und die Wege sind einfach so lang. Das kann ein Kind gar nicht leisten. Und dann soll, weiß ich nicht, wenn der Ball in der Offensive auf dem rechten Flügel ist, dann soll der links außen bloß links an der Linie bleiben. Aber der steht da und kriegt irgendwie 10 Minuten keinen Ball. Also zähl, wenn du auf dem Jugendplatz unterwegs bist, zähl mal Ballkontakte von einem schwächeren Spieler. Da kommst du nicht auf viele. Und das musst du im Training auffangen. Und wie machst du das? Kleine Spielformen, Tore nah beieinander. Du bist schnell in der Offensive. Wenn du den Ball verlierst, dann bist du sofort in der Defensive. Was ist das Kern des Spiels? Mit Ball, Tore erzielen, habe ich den Ball nicht, muss ich verteidigen. Und das geht in kleinen Spielen immer besser als in großen Spielformen. Ganz klar. Aber natürlich gibt es auch Trainer oder Väter und Mütter, die sich da nicht bekehren lassen und das so machen, wie sie das vielleicht selbst erlebt haben.
Ich habe jetzt auch inzwischen nachgeguckt, von Ninho ist die Trainingsporte gemeint. Ich werde ein Erklärvideo dazu in den Show notes verlinken, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Dann könnt ihr euch darüber informieren, wenn es euch interessiert. Aber wir müssen jetzt, glaube ich, langsam mal in die Lizenzen einsteigen, die wir machen können. Jetzt waren wir in der ganz, ganz breiten ehrenamtlichen Basis, oder wahrscheinlich wird wahrscheinlich nur Ehrenamt sein an dieser Basis. Jetzt lass uns mal in der Pyramide langsam nach oben wandern. Wir kommen zur C-Lizenz. Was bedeutet denn C-Lizenz? Was muss man denn mitbringen, um eine solche machen zu können?
Ja, also um die erste Leistungsstufe. Also C-Lizenz gehört noch zu breiten Fußball. Diese Lizenz, sowohl die C-Lizenz, wie auch die Trainer-B-Lizenz, wo man sagen kann, das ist das erste, wo wir von Leistungsfußball sprechen können. Diese Lizenzen werden von den Landesverbänden durchgeführt, von den Verbandssportlehrern in den Landesverbänden, natürlich in Absprache mit dem DFB. Es gibt eine DFB-Ausbildungsordnung. Und ja, die C-Lizenz ist für Trainer für alle Mannschaften auf Kreisebene. Da brauchst du keine Voraussetzungen im Sinne, dass du eine andere Lizenzstufe vorher schon gemacht haben musst. Aber du musst natürlich ein sportliches Attest haben, weil du selber auch eine Übung vormachen musst. Also sollst sportlich schon irgendwie auch tätig sein. Und die erste Leistungslizenz, diese B-Trainer-Lizenz, das ist für Training ab der fünften Liga abwärts. Da sind wir schon in der Oberliga. Da wird ja auch schon gekickt. Und für alle Frauenmannschaften unterhalb der zweiten Liga. Und das kannst du machen, wenn du die C-Lizenz mit einem gewissen Punkteschnitt abgeliefert hast. Zu einer Note von 2, irgendwas, glaube ich. Also du musst schon vorher was geleistet haben, eine Lizenz gehabt haben, damit du überhaupt diese Lizenz machen kannst. Und bei einigen Vereinen musst du, glaube ich, auch einen Eidungs-Test machen. Und du musst vorher 20 Stunden hospitieren an den DFB-Stützpunkten, die es ja flächendeckend über 360 DFB-Stützpunkte gibt. Bei diesen Trainern musst du 20 Stunden vorher hospitieren, dass du mal so einen Einblick bekommst in die erste Stufe des Leistungsfußballs oder wo Talente überhaupt unterwegs sind.
Und um das so zeitlich ein bisschen einzuordnen für die Hörerinnen und Hörer, da hast du bei der C-Lizenz, da wird immer von Lerneinheiten gesprochen, eine Lerneinheit sind 45 Minuten. Das ist wunderbar, weil so ein bisschen ist es wieder ein bisschen wie Studium, wenn man sich mit der Fußballtrainer-Ausbildung befasst. Und da summiert sich dann eben das, was man bei der C-Lizenz mitmacht, die man eben vor allem noch im Amateurbereich braucht, auf 90 Stunden insgesamt. In der B-Lizenz sind es dann auch ebenfalls 90 Stunden, die man da insgesamt quasi wissenvermittelt bekommt, was dann danach in Prüfung abgefahren wird. Also schon ein nicht unerheblicher Aufwand. Richtig.
Plus eben noch die Prüfungsphase. Also ich glaube, sogar in der B-Lizenz sind es, meine ich, sogar 140 Lerneinheiten insgesamt. Aber da können auch jetzt Praktika mit drin sein. Da bin ich jetzt nicht so sicher.
Die 20 Stunden Praktika sind da noch mit drin.
Also es ist schon, wie gesagt, ein sehr, sehr großer Zeitaufwand. Und von der Struktur her sind die Lehrgänge auch unterschiedlich in den Landesverbanden organisiert. Manche machen wirklich das, dass sie von Montags bis Freitags, die Trainerkandidaten wirklich in der Sportschule sind und in der Sportschule des Landesverbandes und dann wirklich ganztägig dort sind und dass der Unterricht von morgens 9 bis abends 17, 18 Uhr geht, dafür musst du dir Urlaub nehmen. Aber damit das eben jeder machen kann, wird das auch aufgeteilt über einen längeren Zeitraum, dass das eben nur an Wochenenden stattfindet oder nur in den Abendstunden, sodass du dir auf diese Stundenanzahl kommst. Aber es ist schon ein erheblicher Zeitumfang, der dort geleistet werden muss. Das ist nicht zu unterschätzen. Und da gehen eben auch Leute nochmal richtig auf die Schulbank, weil du musst da Dinge lernen, bei denen das schon ein bisschen länger her ist. Das ist auch nochmal ein neues Gefühl dann für viele, nochmal für eine Klausur oder für eine Arbeit zu lernen.
Referate halten, endlich mehr Referate halten.
Für Leute, die das vielleicht auch noch nie in ihrem Leben gemacht haben, ist das was Neues. Aber eine wertvolle Erfahrung auf jeden Fall.
Und kosten diese unteren Lizenzen, C-Lizenz und B-Lizenz etwas?
Die kosten was. Das ist aber dann von Landesverband zu Landesverband eigenständig geregelt. Da bin ich jetzt überfragt, wie viel da jetzt aufgerufen wird. Aber ein paar hundert Euro wird das schon kosten, weil wenn du das in der Sportschule machst und dann da auch über Nacht ist, klar wird das auch immer vom jeweiligen Sportbund subventioniert, weil die Sportschulen sind keine Hotelbetriebe. Auch der DFB subventioniert Sportschulen. Aber natürlich kommen da auch Kosten auf die Verbände zu. Und oftmals wird das aber auch von den Vereinen, wo die Trainer sind, gezahlt, weil die Vereine für die Lizenzen dann wieder entsprechende Gelder beim Landessportbund beantragen können und die Trainer dann vielleicht dazu verpflichtet werden, für zwei, drei Jahre zu bleiben, weil der Verein eben gesagt hat, ich finanziere dir deine C-Trainer-Lizenz. Aber dafür hätten wir auch gerne, dass du zumindest mal zwei Jahre unsere Jugend hier trainierst.
Das ist jetzt dann der Bereich der wunderbaren Verbandspolitik. Wir hören vielleicht auch schon aus dem Bereich der Schiedsrichter. Da ist es auch so, dass man ab einer gewissen Größe des Vereins Schiedsrichter stellen muss. Ansonsten zahlt man quasi eine Strafe dafür, dass man keinen Schiedsrichter aus den eigenen Reihen der Allgemeinen hat zur Verfügung gestellt. Also ein bisschen ähnlich ist das.
Und dann kommen im Prinzip die drei höchsten Lizenzen. Die werden zentral vom DFB ausgebildet. Das ist einmal die DFB Elite Jugendlizenz. Und das ist im Prinzip im Leistungsfußball für Trainer, die alles trainieren dürfen, außer A- und B-Junior-Bundesliga. Das ist mittlerweile auch geregelt, dass du für das Training einer A- und B-Junior-Bundesliga zumindest mal die A-Lizenz haben musst. Also da gibt es schon die ersten Einschränkungen, wo du überhaupt tätig sein kannst mit einer Lizenz. Und damit kannst du alle Frauenmannschaften unterhalb der zweiten Bundesliga und alle Juniorinnen trainieren. Aber eben auch im Nachwuchsleistungszentrum. Und dazu benötigst du wiederum eine gute Note in der B-Trainer-Ausbildung, damit du überhaupt eine Zulassung bekommen kannst in dieser Elite-Jugend-Lizenz. Der Run auf diese Lizenzen ist sehr hoch. Da gibt es große Wartelisten immer beim DFB. Es ist kaum zu meistern, dass du alle, was ja sehr gut ist, dass du alle, die Interesse haben, überhaupt in den Lehrgängen unterbekommst. Die Lehrgangsgröße ist da so um die 28.
Du hast einen Aspekt so nebenher fallen lassen, den finde ich noch ganz interessant. Warum wird denn so zwischen Frauenfußball und Männerfußball unterschieden? Wenn wir uns zum Beispiel diese Lizenz angucken, dann darf man im Männerbereich nur im Juniorenbereich trainieren und im Frauenbereich aber bis zur zweiten Frauenbundesliga. Man könnte vielleicht argumentieren, ich habe da schon ein bisschen vorher drüber nachgedacht, weil es mich gewundert hat, man könnte damit argumentieren, dass es vielleicht weniger Stellen gibt für Trainer im Bereich des Frauenfußballs und man deswegen die Tür etwas weiter aufmacht, dass man auch im Profifußball arbeiten kann. Ich finde das Signal ein bisschen komisch. So wie es auch heißt, Fußballlehrer und nicht Fußballlehrerinnen und Lehrer, es haben ja auch schon Frauen diese Ausbildung gemacht, finde ich, das wirkt so von außen betrachtet ein bisschen so, als wäre es im Frauenbereich dann nicht ganz so wichtig, wie gut man ausgebildet ist. Wie es sicherlich nicht gemeint ist.
Du musst ja auch bedenken, dass die Stellen, hast du gerade schon selber gesagt, geringer sind. Und dass auch das Geld, das du verdienst, geringer ist. Und du da eine Hürde machst, die vielleicht unrealistisch zu nehmen ist. Wenn du sagst, ihr müsst alle Lizenzen machen für einen Bereich, wo dann teilweise gar keine Vollzeitstellen da sind.
Ja, das stimmt.
Das ist schwierig.
Da muss man halt ganz klar sein, da geht es auch um Geld. Weil da muss man auch realistisch denken und sagen, wenn du da bis ganz oben bist, hast du ein paar Tausend Euro ausgegeben. Und die kannst du dann nicht wieder rein im Frauenfußballbereich. Im Männerfußballbereich hingegen schon in der Jugend.
Ja, guter Punkt. Da hast du recht. Hast du eigentlich irgendeine Lizenz, Tobi?
Ich habe nur die Lizenz zum Blödsinn reden. Nee, tatsächlich nicht.
Die kann man sicher selbst ausstellen.
Ich habe eine Schiedsrichterlizenz, das ist alles.
Ach schön. Und die erneuerst du auch immer wieder? Man muss ja diese Lizenz erneuern.
Ich habe sie nicht erneuert, aber ich habe sie noch hier rumliegen. Ich könnte sie noch erneuern wieder. Ich bin noch in dem Bereich, wo es wieder erneuern kann, ohne einen ganzen Lehrgang zu machen.
Das heißt, man könnte von Tobias Escher verpfiffen werden.
Ich brauche zu lange für meine Entscheidung.
Ja, und wahrscheinlich fehlt dir halt auch einfach die Taktikkamera, um das zu beurteilen. Okay, aber wir waren bei der DFB Elite Jugendlizenz. Björn, kannst du uns so ein bisschen einen Einblick geben? Wir kommen jetzt ja immer mehr in den professionellen Fußballbereich. Was sind denn da so Lehrinhalte und wie unterscheidet sich denn jetzt zum Beispiel so eine Jugendlizenz von einer B-Lizenz, also der Stufe drunter, von dem, was da vermittelt wird?
Dadurch, dass du einfach in einem höheren Leistungsbereich trainieren kannst und das Niveau der Spieler höher ist, kannst du tiefer in die Materie einsteigen, also tiefer in Thematiken, kannst detaillierter mit den Trainern, ja, Thematiken einfach erarbeiten, sei es in der Individualtaktik, Individualtaktik, Defensivverhalten. Kannst du detaillierter angehen, wie trainierst du das? Oder Gruppentaktiken. Erste Mannschaftstaktik wird dort noch nicht trainiert, sondern es geht nur bis Gruppentaktik. Du erwartest, dass die Trainer mit einfach besseren Spielern arbeiten, darum kannst du andere Inhalte angehen. Das ist eigentlich so der Cut, der da gemacht wird.
Aber es ist interessant, dass man da noch keine Mannschaftstaktik, sondern Gruppentaktik beigebracht bekommt. Kannst du mal kurz den Unterschied umreißen für alle Hörerinnen und Hörer?
Von Individualtaktik sprechen wir, wenn wir ein eins gegen eins haben, sowohl in der Offensive wie in der Defensive. Gruppentaktik im Angriff und Verteidigung, da arbeiten Gruppen von Spielern zusammen, sei es ein Doppelpass, als relativ einfache Variante, ein Hinterlaufen am Flügel, ein Spiel über den Dritten, also Gruppentaktische Dinge gehen dann bis zum 6 gegen 6. Dass du das dort behandelt, du blendest nie ganz das große Ganze des 11 gegen 11 aus, sondern alles, was gemacht wird, wird immer aus dem großen 11 gegen 11 quasi rausgeschnitten. Manche Verbände reden da auch von Spielausschnitten, in denen sie trainieren. Also zum Beispiel Robin Ribéry als klassischer 1 gegen 1 Spieler am Flügel. Dann solltest du dieses 1 gegen 1 auch dort trainieren, wo es am häufigsten vorkommt, am Flügel. Oder das Hinterlaufen kommt am häufigsten am Flügel vor. Dann trainierst du das eben auch dort verortet am Flügel. Und das sind die Prinzipien, die du dort vermittelst. Dann geht es natürlich auch um so Dinge wie physiologische Dinge, Konditionstraining im Juniorenfußball, also Grundprinzipien, Inhalte in den unterschiedlichen Altersklassen, altersgemäße Spielkonzepte, ein Spiel Vor- und Nachbereitung und auch, was du vorhin gefragt hast, pädagogische Leitlinien. Also wie vermittel ich etwas, das Trainieren und Betreuen in den unterschiedlichen Altersklassen, wie gehe ich damit um? Das sind Themen, die dort vermittelt werden. Technik-Training, also im Detail richtiges Demonstrieren und Korrigieren von Techniken, weil dort eben auch viele Basics gelegt werden, die bis oben in den aloistischen Profilbereich einfach super wichtig sind.
Kann man Technik vermitteln, wenn man selbst nicht der größte Techniker unter der Sonne ist? Tobi, du Hund, du hast mich schon mal Fußball spielen sehen, das ist ein unfair advantage und das tut mir auch nachher noch mal leid für dich.
Also du kannst es, wenn du es selbst nicht, wenn du es selbst nicht vormachen kannst, gibt es immer einen in deiner Truppe, der es bestimmt irgendwie kann. Also einen guten Spieler hast du immer, dann kannst du ihn vormachen lassen. Du kannst es aber auch sehr, du kannst es auch runterbrechen, dass du es ganz langsam nur vormachst. Aber du kannst natürlich auch Hilfsmittel nehmen. Also du findest irgendein YouTube-Video, wo diese Technik einfach vorgeführt wird. Es gibt mittlerweile Apps, wo Kinder selbst Tricks irgendwie nachmachen können. Also auch das gibt es. Also du hast ja verschiedene Möglichkeiten, wenn du es selbst nicht kannst, das trotzdem zu vermitteln.
Okay, das ist eben die DFB Elite Jugendlizenz. Allein die Namensgebung, sicherlich auch nicht ganz zufällig gewählt, vermittelt eine gewisse Exklusivität. Ist es dann auch teuer, so eine Lizenz zu erwerben?
Ich glaube, auch da nagezu, ich glaube, das sind so 7, 800 Euro werden das sein, ohne dass ich jetzt aber mich darauf festnage lassen möchte.
Aber es gibt ja schon so eine grobe Großenordnung, das reicht mir schon. Weil du nämlich auch vorhin gesagt hast, dass der Run auf diese Elite-Jugend-Lizenz sei so groß. Kannst du uns kurz einen Einblick geben, wie wählt denn der DFB dann an der Stelle diejenigen auch aus, die diese Lizenz erwerben dürfen? Und warum verknappt man an der Stelle auch die Lizenzen, die vergeben werden? Ist das eine bewusste Entscheidung, kommt die aus den bestehenden Strukturen, die man hat, also dass man nicht mehr Lehrpersonal hat, nicht mehr Räumlichkeiten? Oder kommt es vielleicht auch daher, dass man diesen, man weiß, der Trainermarkt hat nur eine begrenzte Anzahl an Stellen, deswegen kann man jetzt auch nicht 4.000 Fußballlehrer pro Jahr zum Beispiel ausbilden, denn die werden ja auch keine Tätigkeit finden. Woher kommt das, diese Verknappung?
Das ist tatsächlich eine Frage der Ressource, weil sowohl die Landesverbände nicht mehr Verbandsportlehrer anstellen können, weil einfach das Geld nicht da ist, die zu bezahlen. Und auch beim DFB gibt es irgendwie eine Anzahl von Ausbildern, die einfach da nicht mehr leisten können. Es wollen einfach mehr Trainer, die Ausbildung machen, als von den Ausbildern zu leisten ist. Das ist einfach eine Ressourcensache. Und die Auswahl ist jetzt in dem Bereich so, dass du dadurch, dass du vorher bei der Lizenz vorher eine gewisse Note erreicht hast, die Voraussetzungen erfüllt hast. Und dann ist es im Prinzip so nach dem Motto der Erste, der kommt im Lehrgang, der hat auch die Plätze. Also da wird dann sich angemeldet und wenn der Lehrgang voll ist, ist er voll. So geht es einfach.
Also gibt es keine inhaltliche Auswahl?
Da nicht. Das ist dann wirklich erst im Fußballlehrer-Lehrgang, wo wir gleich noch drauf zu sprechen kommen, wo es auch eine Eignungsprüfung gibt.
Ja genau, da freue ich mich jetzt schon drauf, mit dir gleich darüber zu sprechen. Und darüber steht jetzt die A-Lizenz. Mit der A-Lizenz darf man wo dann trainieren, wenn man die hat?
Also da darfst du trainieren alle Männer, alle Männermannschaften unterhalb der dritten Liga. Erste, zweite, dritte Liga ist Profiliga. Da ist Voraussetzung, dass du die Fußballlehrer-Lizenz hast. Also da darfst du alle Männermannschaften und alle Frauen- und Juniorenmannschaften trainieren.
Und brauche ich die Elite-Jugend-Lizenz, um die A-Lizenz machen zu dürfen?
Ja, du brauchst die und du musst mindestens auch mit einer entsprechenden Note abgeschlossen haben. Und musst mindestens ein Jahr mit der Elite-Jugend-Lizenz gearbeitet haben, genauso wie du ein Jahr vorher mit der B-Lizenz gearbeitet haben musst. Das heißt, du hast auf jeden Fall schon mal eine Trainer-Erfahrung, die du definitiv nachweisen kannst. Und das dann auch auf einem entsprechenden Niveau, dass du dort die Berechtigung hast, dich überhaupt anzumelden. Genau. Und die Ausbildungsziele sind, dass du eben als für Aufgaben im höheren Amateurbereich und in der Regionalliga vorbereitet wirst. Da geht es um die Erarbeitung von mannschaftstaktischen Konzepten, also Taktik, Training, Leistungsfußball, Planung, Erarbeitung, Anpassung von mannschaftstaktischen Konzepten, unterschiedliche Spielkonzepte und Systeme, Standardsituation, das Coaching rund ums Spiel, Gegneranalyse, spiel-taktisch Vorbereitung. Das ist schon ein Abbild vom großen Fußball. Das ist schon das ganze Portfolio, das du hast. Konditionstraining, Prinzipien von Belastungssteuerung, anatomische Dinge. Ein kleines Minisportstudium, so würde ich es mal nennen.
Und warum muss ich, wenn ich diese A-Lizenz haben möchte und vielleicht gar nicht im Juniorenfußball arbeiten möchte, warum muss ich dann trotzdem vorher auch die Jugendlizenz erworben haben, die sich ja auf Juniorenausbildung fokussiert? Hätte man das nicht vielleicht auch trennen können? Denn im Grunde sind es ja zwei sehr unterschiedliche Bereiche. Vielleicht gibt es Leute, die schon frühzeitig die Entscheidung treffen, Juniorenfußball ist aus irgendwelchen Gründen gar nicht meins. Ich will mich auf Senjorenfußball konzentrieren.
Ja, die Diskussion gibt es auch, dass man im Prinzip so zwei Strenge an Ausbildungsmöglichkeiten anbietet, um sich einerseits entweder auf den Juniorenfußball zu spezialieren, also vielleicht die Traineralizenz Juniorenfußball und die Traineralizenz Senjorenfußball. Aber, und das Thema hatten wir auch schon, die Inhalte sind im Großen dann gar nicht so unterschiedlich. Natürlich im Umgang mit dem Erwachsenen und im Umgang mit dem Jugendlichen, aber mit einer Alizenz trainierst du jetzt in aller Regel keine Bambini- und F-Junioren-Truppe, sondern dann bist du wahrscheinlich schon bei jungen Erwachsenen und darum ist der Umgang auch nicht so unterschiedlich. Und die Inhalte dann, die Inhalte von mannschaftstaktischen Konzepten, die sind nicht unterschiedlich. Deswegen macht das dann keinen Sinn, da eine Unterscheidung zu treffen.
Und kannst du mal einmal kurz an der Stelle erzählen, wie läuft dann so eine Schlussprüfung ab? Wird ja nicht vergleichbar sein mit einer Abiturprüfung oder Studiumsklausuren, die man so hat. Oder vielleicht doch?
Es gibt verschiedene Prüfungsteile. Also der prozentual am meisten ins Gewicht fällt, der Punktsteil ist die Lehrprobe. Eine Lehrprobe ist, dass du als Trainer für 15 bis 20 Minuten auf dem Platz die Möglichkeit hast, inhaltlich zu arbeiten. Also du machst das mit den Lehrgangsteilnehmern und hast vorher ein Lehrproben-Thema zugelos bekommen. Das kann sein Verbesserung der Viererkette gegen ein Spiel mit zwei Spitzen. Oder Spieleröffnung mit der Dreierkette oder Verbesserung des Flügelspiels im System XY. Und da musst du das einmal schriftlich ausarbeiten, die Lehrprobe. Und dann hältst du quasi den Hauptteil, den Kernteil der Anternehmungseinheit auf den Platz und das wird dann bewertet. Da musst du coachen, da musst du unterbrechen, da musst du einfrieren, da musst du die verschiedenen Möglichkeiten der Korrektur nutzen, sodass es einen Spielfluss gibt, aber dass du dich andererseits auch präsentieren musst. Das ist ein großer Teil. Dann wird eine Klausur geschrieben. Und dann gibt es noch einen mündlichen Vortrag, wo du zu deiner Lehrprobe noch etwas theoretisch sagen kannst. Und dann geht es noch an die Taktik-Tafel, da werden noch ein paar Fragen gestellt zu speziellen Dingen, um einfach nochmal so ein bisschen Hintergrundwissen zu erhaschen. Und daraus gibt es dann so eine Gesamtnote. Das ist schon Stress auch. Also das ist richtig Prüfungsstress, weil du investierst ja was, du investierst nicht nur Zeit, du investierst auch Geld. Und du einerseits für dich selbst willst ja den nächsten Schritt gehen, aber willst vielleicht auch nicht die Blöße geben, wer will schon durch eine Prüfung fallen? Das ist schon Stress, ja.
Was passiert denn, wenn man durch die Prüfung fällt? Kann man wiederholen?
Du kannst wiederholen, ja. Es gibt bei bestimmten Teilen, wenn du nur durch einen Prüfungsteil fällst, dann kannst du auch diesen einen Prüfungsteil nochmal wiederholen.
Gibt es denn da bei so einer Lehrprobe einen richtig und einen falsch? Denn wir haben uns vorhin schon drüber unterhalten. Es gibt ja ganz unterschiedliche Trainertypen. Und auch im Training ist es ja so. Also ein Lucien Favre oder ein Pep Guardiola sind zum Beispiel dafür bekannt, Übungen sehr häufig zu unterbrechen. Ich glaube, Tobi, bei dir habe ich gelesen, dass one more time bei Pep Guardiola so das geflügelte Wort war und jeder wusste, ne ne, wir machen die Übungen jetzt nicht nur noch one more time, weil er wird es eh gleich wieder unterbrechen und wiederholen. Und dann gibt es wahrscheinlich auch Trainer, die viel mehr laufen lassen und die dann vielleicht auch in der Nachbereitung dann nochmal ein paar Dinge sagen. Also die vielleicht auch Spieler mal und Spielerinnen Fehler machen lassen bei der Ausübung von Übungen und dann erst im Nachhinein sagen, so, jetzt gucken wir uns das nochmal an, guck mal, das habt ihr an der Stelle nicht richtig gemacht. Wie kann man denn das bewerten, Björn? Ich finde, da kommen wir ja so in einen Bereich auch fast schon der, ja, also der persönlichen Einschätzung, wie man persönlich das gerne machen würde als Trainer mit rein. Gibt es da eine Linie des DFB? Wie macht man das?
Ja, also das ist sicherlich, da hast du recht, das ist jetzt keine Mathematikklausur, wo eins plus eins gleich zwei ist und es ist richtig und falsch. Das stimmt, aber es gibt natürlich eine Lehrmeinung des DFB und diese Lehrmeinung wird in den Lehrgängen vertreten. Die da gibt's noch. Ich bin sehr glücklich, dass du es so gut kennenzulernen kannst. Ich bin sehr glücklich, dass du es so gut kennenzulernen kannst. Ich bin sehr glücklich, dass du es so gut kennenzulernen kannst. Ich bin sehr glücklich, dass du es so gut kennenzulernen kannst. Ich bin sehr glücklich, dass du es so gut kennenzulernen kannst. Ich bin sehr glücklich, dass du es so gut kennenzulernen kannst. Ich bin sehr glücklich, dass du es so gut kennenzulernen kannst. Ich bin sehr glücklich, dass du es so gut kennenzulernen kannst. Ich bin sehr glücklich, dass du es so gut kennenzulernen kannst. Ich bin sehr glücklich, dass du es so gut kennenzulernen kannst. Und die Teilnehmer bekommen ja mit, wie man den Fußball auch sieht. Und es geht weniger darum, dass es taktisch richtig oder falsch ist, auch das, aber es geht vor allen Dingen um die Vermittlung auch. Wie vermittelt der Trainer das dort jetzt? Redet er immer in eine sich bewegende Gruppe, wo keiner zuhört? Kommen die Informationen, die er den Spielern gibt, kommen die bei den Spielern an, setzen dies um? Wenn sie nicht umsetzen, was er vorher gesagt hat, korrigiert er es? Wie korrigiert er es? Friert er ein? Macht er es im Simultan-Coaching? Also da gibt es verschiedene Tools, die er anwenden kann, und das wird eben dann auch bewertet. Kommt ein gewisser Spielfluss zustande überhaupt? Oder ist es ganz abgehackt? Also im Prinzip müsste es so sein, dass außen – ich nenne es mal – die Rentner-Truppe steht und ohne dass die wissen, was für ein Thema ist, müssten die eigentlich sagen können, hier geht es um Flügelspiel oder hier geht es um Spieleöffnung. Also wenn das Thema Spieleöffnung ist und du bist irgendwie ständig vor dem gegnerischen Tor, dann ist ja der Schwerpunkt irgendwie nicht Spieleöffnung, sondern dann ist es irgendwie Torabschluss. Oder wenn es um Torabschluss geht und du bist ständig immer hinten beim Torwart geht es los und es kommen wenig Aktionen zum Torabschluss, dann ist das Thema irgendwie auch verfehlt. Überspitzt formuliert haben wir es immer gesagt, dass der Rentner draußen eigentlich sehen müsste, was bei euch Thema ist, ohne dass er das Thema weiß.
Ergänzend dazu noch, es gibt natürlich aber auch einen Falsch. Wahrscheinlich passiert das auf der Ebene, auf dem Niveau sehr selten, aber wenn ich eine Viererkette aufbauen, mit einer Viererkette trainieren lassen soll und ich stelle meine Viererkette alle auf eine Höhe nebeneinander, dann ist es natürlich falsch, in dem Sinne. Also es gibt ja schon natürlich Abstufungen.
Absolut, es gibt auch Falsch, das stimmt.
Wie ist denn das mit Trainingsformen? Ich stelle mir das fast wie so ein Geheimhandel vor, dass man immer mal wieder… wieder... Björn, erkennt man denn dann diese Spielphilosophie, die ein Trainer hat, schon auch bei dieser A-Lizenz, Ausbildung und der Lehrprobe dazu? Wie entwickelt man seine eigene Spielphilosophie? Hast du eine? Also, das ist ja so ein bisschen, es hört sich so ein bisschen an wie der Heilige Gral und wird vielleicht auch manchmal ein bisschen verklärt.
Eine A-Lizenz? Ich bin sehr glücklich, dass du es so gut kennenzulernen kannst. Ich bin sehr glücklich, dass du es so gut kennenzulernen kannst. Ich bin sehr glücklich, dass du es so gut kennenzulernen kannst. Ich bin sehr glücklich, dass du es so gut kennenzulernen kannst. Ich bin sehr glücklich, dass du es so gut kennenzulernen kannst. Ich bin sehr glücklich, dass du es so gut kennenzulernen kannst. Ich bin sehr glücklich, dass du es so gut kennenzulernen kannst. Ich bin sehr glücklich, dass du es so gut kennenzulernen kannst. Ich bin sehr glücklich, dass du es so gut kennenzulernen kannst. Vielleicht für ihre eigene Spielphilosophie oder diese dann im Idealfall erweitern oder verfeinern. Im Fußballlehrer-Lehrgang selber geht es ganz stark ums Thema eigene Spielphilosophie, weil da schreibst du sogar eine Hausarbeit drüber und sollst das, was du sowieso in deinem Kopf hast, wie du Fußball spielen möchtest, was du aber vorher, ich würde sagen, die allerwenigsten zu Papier gebracht haben, dazu wirst du ein Stück weit gezwungen. Ich bin sehr glücklich, dass du es so gut kennenzulernen kannst. Ich bin sehr glücklich, dass du es so gut kennenzulernen kannst. Ich bin sehr glücklich, dass du es so gut kennenzulernen kannst. Das ist ein Abriss aus den Lehrgangsthemen. Das kann dir auch nach dem Lehrgang als Workbook dienen. Da weiß ich auch, dass Trainer das gemacht haben und das als Grundlage genommen haben. Ich habe mich mal hingesetzt und habe das auf x Seiten richtig niedergeschrieben. Wie will ich spielen? Wie will ich meine Mannschaft führen? Wie will ich das Team ums Team führen? Das ist herausfordernd für die Teilnehmer, aber absolut wertvoll. Da ist man auch stolz, wenn man das dann mal zu Papier gebracht hat.
Interessanterweise habe ich auch von Trainern gehört, dass sie da aber auch Sachen aussparen, weil sie Angst haben, dass irgendjemand anders ihre Philosophie mitbekommt. Das schreiben sie halt nur die Hälfte aus und vielleicht die andere Hälfte, die auch interessant ist, lassen sie dann weg.
Das kann sein.
Damit im Kauf Ärger zu bekommen.
Das kann durchaus sein. Sie sollen es ja auch nicht für uns schreiben. Von mir aus lassen sie auch die Hälfte weg. Und haben das irgendwie auf einer separaten Festplatte. Da müssen wir auch gar nicht alles wissen. Letztendlich, wo es darum geht, dass die Anregung dazu gegeben wird. Setzt euch hin, schreibt es mal nieder. Das, was ihr eh an Wissen in eurem Kopf habt, das bringt euch etwas. Und bewertet wird da letztendlich – kann ich ja nicht bewerten, ob die Spielphilosophie super ist oder nicht – sind die Formalienrichtlinien einer wissenschaftlichen Arbeit eingehalten? Stimmt das mit den Absätzen? Sieht das einigermaßen nach strukturierten Gedanken aus? Oder ist das Vogelwild? Und ist das schlüssig, wenn ich die Spielphilosophie wie Guardiola mit viel Ballbesitz und Ballzirkulation habe? Wenn dann mein Trainingsinhalt nur lange Bälle sind, dann ist das natürlich nicht schlüssig. Also sind solche Gedanken stimmig. Das wird dann eher bewertet. Aber der Trainer setzt sich auf jeden Fall hin und schreibt es mal nieder.
Jetzt warst du von 2013 bis 2016 mit in diesem Fußballlehrer-Jahrgang involviert. Wie viele der 31 Spielprinzipien von Julian Nagelsmann kennst du denn zum Beispiel? Oder wie tief bist du drin? Wenn du jetzt Fußball guckst von Leuten, mit denen du quasi da in der Ausbildung zusammengearbeitet hast, erkennst du häufig Dinge wieder.
Weil ich ja nicht in der täglichen Trainingsarbeit mit den ehemaligen Trainerkandidaten bin, kann ich das nicht so beurteilen. Man liest Dinge wie jetzt bei Julian über seine Prinzipien, die man vielleicht im Lehrgang auch schon mal gehört hat, die vielleicht – weiß ich jetzt nicht, ob er alle preisgegeben hat dort, würde ich verstehen, wenn das vielleicht nicht gemacht hat. Aber ich erkenne eher die Persönlichkeit dahinter wieder. Also wie habe ich den Menschen dort erlebt in persönlichen Gesprächen, im Unterricht, auf dem Platz und wie sehe ich den jetzt vornehmlich? In einer Pressekonferenz. Und da sehe ich ganz häufig eine ganz starke Authentizität, erkenne den Menschen, den ich da zehn Monate auch gesehen habe und merke, dass der weder zehn Monate im Lehrgang Schauspieler war, wie jetzt dann in der Pressekonferenz. Also das ist glaube ich so eher das, was ich dann sehe.
Okay, jetzt haben wir gerade damit schon indirekt gesagt, wie lange eigentlich so der Fußballlehrer dauert. Lass uns mal kurz darüber sprechen, wie man sich dafür bewirbt. Denn hier haben wir nur 24 Teilnehmer pro Jahrgang. Zehn Monate eben ist man dann mit dieser Ausbildung beschäftigt. Die Kosten werden so auf 9.000 Euro plus Nebenkosten wie Anreise und Unterkunft taxiert. Das habe ich jetzt aus einem Artikel über den Fußballlehrer-Jahrgang. Genau. Und gleichzeitig gehen aber ja viele, viele Bewerbungen dafür ein. Denn nur mit dem Fußballlehrer darf man in den allerhöchsten Spielklassen trainieren. Das heißt, der Run darauf ist sehr groß. Wie wählt da der DFB aus? Denn das ist ja ein bisschen anders als bei den Linienklassen.
Also die Voraussetzungen sind nochmal etwas spezieller. Natürlich, du musst die A-Lizenz besitzen. Du musst mindestens ein Jahr nicht nur mit der A-Lizenz auf irgendeinem Niveau trainiert haben, sondern du musst mindestens ein Jahr Cheftrainer mindestens in der sechsten Liga gewesen sein. Das ist immerhin Verbandsliga. Oder ein Jahr Cheftrainer in der A- oder B-Jugend Bundesliga gewesen sein. Oder in der Frauenbundesliga oder Stützpunktkoordinator gewesen sein. Oder ein Jahr Co-Trainer in einer der Profiligen gewesen sein. Wenn du ein sportwissenschaftliches Studium hattest und ein Jahr Vollzeit im Nachwuchsleistungszentrum gearbeitet hast, dann kannst du das auch machen. Also da sieht man schon, da kann sich jetzt nicht jeder, der eine A-Lizenz hat, auch anmelden, sondern du musst mit der A-Lizenz dann auch schon auf einem Niveau gearbeitet haben. Und das zeugt, daraus lässt sich schließen, dass die Trainer alle auch schon eine große Erfahrung haben, die meisten. So, die können sich anmelden für eine Eignungsprüfung, wenn sie diese Voraussetzungen erfüllen. Da werden, da gehen so 70, 80 Anmeldungen für eine Eignungsprüfung ein, jedes Jahr. Die erfüllen dann formal nicht alle Kriterien. Ich sag mal so 60, 65 im Schnitt, das ist jedes Jahr anders. 60 rund kommen dann zu so einer Eignungsprüfung. Für 24 Plätze. Kannst du dir vorstellen, das ist immer ein Hauen und Stechen. Du willst rein in diesen Lehrgang. Der, der maßgeblich über dein Leben entscheiden kann. Also der entscheidet darüber, wie es für dich beruflich, wenn du es im Fußball machen willst, weitergeht. Und bei dieser Eignungsprüfung werden Folgen – ja, also so war es immer. Es wird eine Lehrprobe gehalten. Die Teilnehmer mussten etwas schriftlich darlegen, eine Klausur schreiben. Es gibt so ein mündliches Gespräch, um den Trainer auch näher kennenzulernen, zu durchleuchten.
Der heiße Stuhl wird in manchen Berichten genannt. Frank Wormuth, der es ja lange Zeit gemacht hat beim DFB, hat das auch selbst so bezeichnet, dass man da wirklich, wie in Unternehmen, in Assismencentern, auch mal die Bewerberinnen und Bewerber ein bisschen pieks und guckt, wie reagieren die, wenn wir die jetzt da ein bisschen grillen und unter Druck setzen.
Ja, das ist etwas, womit Frank Wormuth gerne mal so ein bisschen gearbeitet hat, mal bewusst ein bisschen Stress verursachen, wie es jetzt aktuell ist. Der Frank ist ja in die niederländische Erste Liga, Heraklis Almeo, jetzt gegangen. Und der Daniel Nitzkowski hat es übernommen. Inwiefern sich das jetzt ändert, auch von der Struktur. Das muss man jetzt abwarten, ob da auch Einflüsse vom Daniel reinkommen. Da bin ich mir ganz sicher, weil er sicher auch seine eigenen Ideen hat. Das wird interessant. Aber klar, willst du den Trainer auch sehen, vertritt er eine Meinung weiterhin, wenn man vielleicht ihn ein bisschen aus dem Gleichgewicht bringt. Und da ergibt sich dann auch ein Bild darüber. Und es ist einfach unheimlich schwer, da jetzt zu sagen, das sind die 24 Richtigen. Was man sagen kann, ist, man will aus einem gewissen Berufsfeld die Leute auch rausbringen. Also die Gruppe ist heterogen. Es soll eine heterogene Gruppe sein, eine wissensheterogene Gruppe. Es sollen Leute dabei sein, die ein Sportstudium hinter sich haben. Weil die können den Leuten, die vielleicht einen Profiker hinter sich haben, in gewissen Dingen unterstützen, weil die einen Wissensvorsprung haben. Die Leute, die Profis waren, können ihr Wissen einbringen für die Leute, die nie im Profibereich gespielt haben. Wie geht es denn da eigentlich ab in so einer Profikavine? Die Leute, die im Jugendbereich arbeiten, bringen ihren Input rein. Und dann gibt es noch Leute aus dem Verband, die von der Seite kommen, wie lehre ich denn überhaupt den Fußball? Die Gruppe ist bewusst heterogen, und so wird es auch zusammengestellt, dass aus allen Ecken des Fußballs das Wissen zusammenkommt. Weil dort soll nicht nur per Frontalunterricht gelehrt werden, sondern es wird einfach ganz, ganz viel diskutiert, Meinungen ausgetauscht und sich so ein gesamtes Rundumbild vom Fußball soll sich dort ergeben. Und da versucht man dann eben die 24 Richtigen auszuwählen.
Jetzt hat im Jahrgang 2012, 2013 ein gewisser Björn Müller den Fußballlehrer gemacht. Wie hast du denn damals das Auswahlverfahren als Kandidat erlebt?
Also, zwar ist es stressig. Stressig im Sinne von, dass du dir den Stress machst, dass du es selber machst. Du bist halt schon unter Druck, weil du willst es halt machen. Wenn du es dieses Jahr nicht schaffst, musst du ein Jahr warten. Und wenn du es da nicht schaffst, musst du ein zweites Jahr warten. Es gibt Kandidaten, die sind dort vier- fünfmal mehrere Jahre dran geblieben und haben das immer wieder probiert. Und dann siehst du über Jahre vielleicht eine Entwicklung. Ich war einfach sehr glücklich, dass ich das sofort im ersten Anlauf geschafft habe. Irgendwie hat es geschafft, die Leute da zu überzeugen, dass ich eingehöre. Aber es ist schon – es ist einerseits ein großer Druck. Du weißt, dass die anderen deine Konkurrenten sind, aber es ist geprägt von unheimlich gegenseitigen Helfen. Also da sind dann 60 Trainer, alle wollen rein, 24 Plätze sind nur da. Aber trotzdem unterstützt du dich in jeder Zeit. Du bist für den anderen da, du gibst alles in den Trainingseinheiten, auch wenn da jetzt ein Trainer gerade in Lehrprobe hält, der ja eigentlich deinen Platz will. Das ist schon mal eine tolle Erfahrung gewesen, alleine das durchgemacht zu haben.
Und wie transparent ist dieser Vorgang? Denn ohne, dass ich was unterstellen möchte, aber das hört sich so an, als könnte man da auch Leute aus dem Profi-Fußball raushalten, wenn man das wollte.
Wir haben versucht, eine größtmögliche Objektivität reinzulegen, und zwar, dass die, also am Ende kommt so eine Gesamtnote raus und die hat sich halt aus verschiedenen Leistungen, die die Trainer dort erbracht haben, ergeben. Also wir haben mal eine Vornote eingeführt. Also was eine Vornote hat sich daraus zusammengesetzt, wie lange ist der denn schon Trainer überhaupt? Wie hoch hat er trainiert? Was für eine Spielerkarriere hat er hinter sich? Es gibt immer mehr eine steigende Anzahl von gut ausgewöhnten Lehrgangsteilnehmern mit sportwissenschaftlichem Studium, aber mit einem starken theoretischen Wissen, was jetzt nicht schlimm ist. Die werden immer jünger, haben somit weniger praktische Spielerfahrung, wo wir immer gesagt haben, das wäre doch aber toll, wenn die lange spielen. Die sollen selber mal junger Spieler gewesen sein in der Kabine und von einer Massagebank geflogen sein, weil da jetzt der 35-Jährige reinkommt und der 18-Jährige da nichts drauf zu suchen hat. Und die sollen selber aber auch mal erfahrener Spieler gewesen sein. Die sollen Trainerwechsel erlebt haben, weil das einfach eine wichtige Erfahrung ist, um selber Trainer zu sein. Nicht zwingend notwendig, wie wir das an Beispielen auch sehen. Julian Nagelsmann, Domey Nikoutidesko, ja nicht zwingend notwendig, aber sicherlich auch nicht abträglich. Und jetzt haben wir einen Faden verloren.
Ihr habt quasi das Bewerbungsverfahren objektiviert.
Objektiviert, dass wir versuchen, ja, dass derjenige dort wirklich das was versuchen, objektiv zu machen und denen auch sagen, ihr bekommt Bewertungen für diese und jene Leistung, die ihr hier bringt. Und natürlich kann man darüber streiten, ob man das so oder so bewertet, aber sie kennen ja durch die vorherigen Lizenzen die Lehrmeinung und wissen ja, wie Fußball gesehen wird oder wie Dinge einfach dort, ja, angegangen werden. Und daher ist es eigentlich bekannt.
Und bekommen dann auch diejenigen, die eine Absage bekommen, aufgezeigt, wie sie in verschiedenen Kategorien abgeschnitten haben? Also richtig, dass man ihnen dann die Punkte da vorlegt und nicht nur einfach in einem Gespräch mitgibt? Weil es ist ja wirklich eine goldene Tür. Und wenn die für dich zu ist, dann kannst du in Deutschland keine Profimannschaft trainieren. Deswegen liegt da ja auch eine große Verantwortung beim DFB.
Es wird jetzt explizit nicht jedes Ergebnis den Trainern mitgeteilt, aber mehrfach und explizit gesagt, ihr könnt, wenn ihr keine Zusage bekommt, immer den Lehrgangsleiter – in dem Fall war das Frank Wormuth – anrufen und euch aufzeigen lassen und könnt durchgehen, wie waren denn die Prüfungsleistungen? Und das haben immer wieder auch Trainer wahrgenommen gerade, die das noch mal im nächsten Jahr probiert haben. Und da hat der Frank Wormuth dann Telefonate geführt, wenn Trainer angerufen haben und hat den dann eben aufgezeigt, weil so eine Kommission besteht halt aus ganz vielen Leuten. Das ist nicht Frank Wormuth, der das entscheidet, sondern da gibt es den Lehrgangsleiter, da gibt es drei, vier Ausbilder vom DFB, die daran teilnehmen. Es gibt einen Rechtsbeistand, der daran teilnimmt, das auch alles rechtlich vonstatten geht, die Dozenten, die das Thema Sportpsychologie im Unterricht auch vermitteln. Also sportpsychologisch wird dort auch draufgeschaut, wenn man denn da was raussehen möchte, wie sind sie da strukturiert. Also wird von ganz vielen Leuten durchleuchtet und je mehr dort teilnehmen, desto objektivierbar wird es ja auch. Und meistens liegt man auch wirklich so in einem Ranking auch meistens relativ gleich.
So, dann haben wir jetzt 24 Kandidatinnen und Kandidaten. Ist ganz wichtig dazuzusagen, auch Frauen machen natürlich den Fußballlehrer, auch wenn er nicht Fußballlehrerinnen und Lehrer heißt und das auch schon sehr, sehr lange. Und jetzt geht's los. Zehn Monate in Unterrichtsblöcken. Was bekommt man jetzt in diesen zehn Monaten vermittelt?
Wie viel Zeit haben wir noch?
Das richtet sich nach euch. Wir sind schon. Wir sind jetzt schon drüber.
Ich habe. Da könnte ich jetzt natürlich zehn Monate da steckt so, so, so, so viel drin. Ich versuche mal einen kurzen Abriss zu machen. Also das Ganze findet ja in der Hennes-Weißweiler Akademie in der Sportschule in Hennefstadt und der Lehrgang über zehn Monate, circa 40 bis 44 Wochen. Davon sind 20 Wochen, die wirklich vor Ort sind, also die Hälfte des Lehrgangs vor Ort in der Hennes-Weißweiler Akademie. Vor Ort heißt Unterricht montags bis mittwochs en bloc von morgens acht bis, weiß ich nicht, bis abends 18, 19 Uhr, aber man sitzt auch noch bis in die Nacht. Dann gibt es Praktikumsphasen. Du machst ein Praktikum bei einem Bundesligisten im Idealfall oder einem Zweitligisten, so hoch es eben geht. Das geht sieben bis acht Wochen, nicht am Stück, sondern du bist einmal in der Vorbereitungsphase des Bundesligisten dort, einmal in der Wettkampfphase und dann in der Wintervorbereitung. Da sind wir immer abhängig von den Trainern. Nehmen die einen Hospitanten auf. Wir haben den Leuten in der Fußballlehrerausbildung immer gesagt, denkt dran, wenn ihr mal da oben seid und wir rufen an, bitte nehmt einen, weil jetzt wollt ihr ja auch irgendwo rein. Ich hatte das große Glück, das beim BVB zu machen, das war einfach fantastisch und habe da unfassbare Einblicke bekommen. Also das ist das Thema. Dann machen sie ein Praktikum im Verband, dass sie das auch kennen. Und es gibt immer eine Analyse-Reise am Anfang des Lehrgangs. Es findet immer zweijährig, also entweder eine U19 Europameisterschaft oder eine U21 Europameisterschaft. Da fährt der Lehrgang zwei Wochen hin, um dort eben die Spiele zu analysieren. Also das mal so vom groben Rahmen. Ja, und dann geht es los in der Reise. Es gibt Einführungswochen, da geht es direkt los mit Rhetorik. Wie gehe ich mit dem Computer um? Wie handle ich das, dass ich jetzt hier ständig irgendwelche Powerpoint-Präsentationen machen muss? Dann geht es schon auf diese spitzen Fußballanalyse. Man reist zu einer Europameisterschaft, ist in Dreierteams vor Ort, im Stadion, muss die Spiele analysieren, muss Scout spielen, stärken Schwächenanalyse des Gegners, erstellt darüber einen Bericht. Muss sie dem in so einem Rollenspiel, dem Cheftrainer vorstellen, diesen Bericht. Und so geht das immer weiter mit allen Themen. Also drei Kernthemen gibt es. Das ist das Fach Fußballlehre, dann gibt es das Fach Physiologie, dann gibt es das Fach Psychologie. Und was auch noch gemacht wird, ist Ernährungslehre und Regelkunde. Weil der Trainer eben auch erstaunlicherweise gar nicht das ganze Regelwerk kennt und es da auch lustige Situationen gibt, über die man eben auch – Lutz Wagner macht das übrigens in einer fantastischen Art und Weise. Sehr, sehr lustig und aber auch sehr lehrreich. Ja, und so gehst du da durch und jetzt können wir ins Detail gehen, was da in den einzelnen Fächern gemacht wird.
Ja, ich fürchte, da wir – Ich habe euch ja eigentlich sogar mit einer anderen Zeitvorgabe hier reingeholt, deswegen müssen wir die Details vielleicht wann anders machen. Es wird auch definitiv immer weiter hier im Rasenfunk bleiben. Es zeigt auf jeden Fall schon mal den Umfang, finde ich ganz gut, auch die Intensität dieser Ausbildung. Jetzt hat der DFB ja dann an dieser Stelle auch ein hohes Interesse, eine Lehrmeinung, die du vorhin auch schon angesprochen hast, zu vermitteln. Kannst du festmachen, wie hat sich denn diese Lehrmeinung verändert? Es gibt ein Narrativ und dieses Narrativ sagt, nach der völlig verkorksten Europameisterschaft 2000 hat der DFB sich reformiert, die Nachwuchsleistungszentren eingeführt und auch die Trainerausbildung maßgeblich verändert. Es gab die Pläne zwar schon vor dieser EM, aber danach wurden die Gelder bewilligt, deswegen fällt das zeitlich zumindest zusammen. Wie hat sich denn die Ausbildung verändert in den letzten Jahren?
Kann man das beschreiben? Eine große Maßnahme ist erstmal, dass nach 2002 die Nachwuchsleistungszentren ins Leben gerufen wurden, diese ganzen Stützpunkte, dass kein Talent mehr durch das Raster fallen kann, dass die Talente einfach auch mehr Input bekommen. Matthias Sammer als Sportdirektor, den du auch in einer fantastischen Folge bei dir drin hattest, das war wirklich sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr gut. Auch er, du hast das so genannt, er hat diesen Rundumblick als selber Profi-Spieler, dann war er Profi-Trainer, erfolgreicher noch dazu. Er war beim Verband, jetzt ist er beim Fernsehen, dann war er Sportdirektor, also er hat wirklich diesen 360-Grad-Blick und das merkst du wirklich auch in jedem Gespräch, finde ich bei ihm. Also das noch mal, super Folge, kann ich noch jedem empfehlen. So und dann gab es das Thema Qualifizierungsoffensive, weil der Matthias damals gesagt hat, der Trainer ist der Schlüssel, der Trainer ist der Schlüssel zu einem, was bringt, also der Trainer gibt den Input an die Spieler und darum müssen die Trainer gut ausgebildet werden, darum wurde erstmal auch die Masse der Lehrgänge nach oben geschossen, dass einfach viel mehr Angebot da ist, es wurde einfach auch darauf aufmerksam gemacht, das wusste man früher vielleicht auch gar nicht so, dass man verschiedenste Fortbildungsmaßnahmen wahrnehmen kann und die Lehrmeinung, die hat sich nicht einmal geändert, die ändert sich im Prinzip ständig, weil bei jedem großen Turnier wird eine umfangreiche Analyse des DFB gemacht, also da fahren Unnationaltrainer zu den großen Turnieren, Wir werden ausbilderfahren dorthin und nehmen das Turnier im Prinzip von vorne bis hinten auseinander. Welche neuen Trends gibt es? Jetzt haben wir gerade den Trend, dass Spielsysteme ständig gewechselt werden, sogar während des Spiels. Das ist ja etwas, was wir verfolgen die letzten Jahre. Das werden wir bei der nächsten WM wahrscheinlich auch sehen. Das gab es ja früher noch nicht. Und diese Trends, da versucht man dann sogar, einen Ausblick zu schaffen. Was ist jetzt Trend bei dieser WM? Was erwarten wir jetzt vielleicht schon bei der Europameisterschaft? Oder wo sind Schwächen? Woran müssen wir arbeiten? Ein Defizit ist das offensive 1 gegen 1. Wir haben viel weniger Spieler, die 1 gegen 1 gehen, weil vorher dieses Ballbesitzspiel postuliert wurde. Und dann ist aber verloren gegangen, dass die Spieler, weil die Trainer das auch nicht gefordert haben, dass die Spieler ins Risiko gehen sollen. Und 1 gegen 1 gehen sollen. Wir haben da nicht mehr viele Spieler, die das machen. Und daraus lassen sich dann Inhalte für die Ausbildung ableiten, die man dort als Schwerpunkt setzt, für vielleicht die nächsten zwei Jahre. Und diese Schwerpunkte tragen die Trainer natürlich wieder in die Vereine und in die Ausbildung der Spieler. Und somit hofft man dann da wieder, Spieler mit dem entsprechenden Schwerpunkt herauszunehmen. Deswegen ist das ein ständiger Wandel, ein ständiges Beobachten des großen Spiels.
Hochspannend, da kann man auch viel bei YouTube finden. Und trotzdem ist es so ein bisschen wie so ein Geheimbund, wenn die Fußballlehrer sich da auf ihren Tagungen treffen. Und dann gibt es ein paar Gespräche, die findet man eben bei YouTube. Was müssten denn der Tobi oder ich tun, dass wir da mal Mäuschen spielen dürfen? Denn im Grunde wäre es doch eigentlich auch für die journalistische Berichterstattung, hat es ja viele Mehrwerte zu wissen, wie sieht der DFB den modernen Fußball, welche Akzente möchte er setzen. Vielleicht führt das ja auch zu einer… Ja, es macht, glaube ich, die Berichterstattung stellt es auf eine kompetentere Basis, wenn man da ein bisschen mehr auch teilhaben kann als Journalist.
Um da kurz einzuhaken, ich bin da meistens vom Bund Deutscher Fußballlehrer bei diesen Fortbildungsveranstaltungen, die dann auch gestreamt werden im Internet.
Stark, Tobi. Wie bist du da hingekoscht?
Weil du da bist du die, ja, die als Journalist einfach, also die lassen da Journalisten zu. Das ist ja in dem Sinne kein Geheimbund tatsächlich. Also dann abends zum Grillen werde ich dann immer freundlich rauskomplimentiert.
Wie viele Journalisten sind denn da? Also ich werde dann auf jeden Fall beim nächsten Mal auch mit dabei sein.
Nee, nicht viele tatsächlich. Michi Leopold von Sky ist meistens da, der moderiert die Veranstaltungen da sehr häufig. Ansonsten trifft man da nicht viele Kollegen tatsächlich, weil das sind auch immer irgendwie in der Off-Season, wenn gerade nichts los ist und dann auch meistens nicht, also in Zertralorten, die relativ zentral gelegen sind, aber nicht für die Redaktion relativ zentral gelegen sind. Vor zwei Jahren waren sie in Fulda. Ich glaube, letztes Jahr war es in Bochum.
Und jetzt ist es im schönen Dresden, Ende Juli ist es im Dresden. Das ist dann der sogenannte ITK, das ist der Internationale Trainerkongress, der vom Bund Deutscher Fußballlehrer einmal im Jahr durchgeführt wird. Also es gibt regionale Fortbildungen, die sind flächendeckt in Deutschland überall, über fünf, sechs Stunden an einem Tag, aber eben einmal im Jahr auch einen großen, dreitägigen Trainerkongress, wo mittlerweile ca. 1000 Trainer teilnehmen. Da brauchst du eine A-Lizenz oder eben die Fußballlehrer-Lizenz zu. Und dort präsentiert nach großen Turnieren auch der DFB immer die Analyse des großen Turniers. Und das ist sogar auf der BDFL-Seite – ich glaube, da muss man auch nicht mehr Mitglied sein – ist das sogar teilweise öffentlich einzusehen.
Ja, ich glaube nicht alles. Ich habe mal versucht, die Analysen zur Europamannschaft zu finden. Aber auf jeden Fall weiß ich jetzt, welchen Bereich im Juli ich mir mal freihalte und dann mal nett anfrage, ob man da nicht vorbeigucken könnte. Denn ich finde das einfach hochinteressant und finde eigentlich sollte das dazugehören, ich muss ja jetzt kein Fußballtrainer sein und ich muss auch nicht der Übertaktiker sein. Aber ich sollte schon wissen, was der DFB über den aktuellen Fußball denkt, damit ich dann besser einschätzen kann, wie die Nationalmannschaft auftritt, wie vielleicht manche Vereinstrainer dann auch Schwerpunkte anders setzen, als in den Spielzeiten davor. Ich finde das bemerkenswert.
Da möchte ich ergänzen, dass der DFB hat ja sogenannte Leitlinien für ihre Spielphilosophie entwickelt. Leitlinien für die Offensive, Leitlinien für die Defensive. Angefangen noch mit Hansi Flick, das war so sein Hauptschaffen beim DFB, als er als Sportdirektor dort war. Und da ist der DFB auch durch die Landesverbände gezogen und hat in allen möglichen Vorträgen das gehalten. Und da gibt es auch die Leitlinien, die einzusehen auf der DFB-Seite. Also das ist jetzt so von daher kein Geheimnis.
Ja, die finde ich allerdings relativ generell, also die kenne ich, aber die sind so übergreifend, das hätte ich auch so grob erwartet.
Ja, das war immer ein Vorwurf an diese Leitlinien und genau das meinst du wahrscheinlich in den Gesprächen oder in den Vorträgen, wenn dann detailliert darauf eingegangen wird, was denn jetzt dahinter steckt, bekommt man noch mal einen tieferen Einblick und der ist jetzt nicht so öffentlich, da gebe ich dir recht, da kann man jetzt nichts rausziehen, das stimmt.
Gut, ich kenne ja jetzt zumindest schon mal einen, der beim DFB tätig war und Co-Trainer in der Bundesliga, vielleicht kann man da ja mal so in Off-the-Record-Gesprächen dann noch ein paar Informationen rausholen. Jetzt, wenn wir über den Fußballlehrer-Jahrgang sprechen, ich habe es auch deswegen ins Intro mit reingenommen, was Domenico Tedesco da gesagt hat, er wurde natürlich angesprochen auf seine Beziehung zu Julian Nagelsmann, beide waren im selben Jahrgang und der eine war Jahrgangsbeste und der andere eben nicht. Diese Konzentration auf die Noten, ist das ein mediales Phänomen, das du gerechtfertigt findest, dass da immer drüber berichtet wird, wer war jetzt der Jahrgangsbeste in diesem Fußballlehrer-Jahrgang? Es könnte ja auch sein, dass es mal einen Jahrgang aus total Nulpen gab und dann ist der einäugige der König unter den Blinden überspitzt gesprochen.
Auch er konnte den Erfolg der Mannschaft nicht verhindern, solche Trainer gibt es auch. Das kann ich nicht sagen, ob es pro Jahrgang Teilnehmer gibt, die darauf aus sind, besser zu werden. Wenn es so wäre, würde ich es ihm nicht vorwerfen, wenn er danach strebt. Die Note sagt jetzt nicht aus, dass er im richtigen Leben der beste Trainer ist. Was ihm die Note natürlich gibt, ist einen gewissen Vorsprung. Es öffnet vielleicht Türen, weil die Jahrgangsbesten, die werden immer damit tituliert, wie die Weltmeister von 90, die sind heute immer noch Weltmeister und der Jahrgangsbeste ist halt immer Jahrgangsbester gewesen.
Genau, das ist wieder der BM-Torschütze Mario Götze.
Ja, richtig, genau. Und das öffnet dir am Anfang vielleicht die eine oder andere Tür, dass du einfach Gefragter bist, weil du medial natürlich auch vertreten bist und die vielleicht noch gar nicht so bekannt sind, die Jahrgangsbesten. Das kann schon sein, aber das heißt bei weitem nicht, dass das dann auch der beste Trainer ist draußen. Da gehört ja auch eine Menge an Glück zu, dass du den passenden Verein, die passende Mannschaft hast. Also da sind ja zu viele Unwägbarkeiten noch dann auch dabei. Aber es ist sicherlich eine Tendenz, dass das schon dann auch die Trainer sind, die das, was dort inhaltlich gemacht wurde, zumindest relativ gut repräsentieren konnten. Das ist ja auch eine Leistung, dass du einfach Dinge, die du lernst, dann reproduzieren kannst. Und von daher sagt es nichts aus, dass es jetzt auch die besten Trainer werden.
Dann ist es wie jede Note in jedem Lebensabschnitt, die man sich auch mal selber geholt hat. Tobi, spricht das vielleicht auch so ein bisschen, ist das Anzeichen für den Trainer-Hype, den wir gerade erleben, dass so diese jungen, aufstrebenden neuen Talente, die auch zum Teil andere Biografien haben, als man es ganz lange im Fußball hatte, die werden auf unheimlich hohe Podeste gestellt. Und deswegen lächzt man fast nach diesen Jahrgangsbesten. Das ist ja fast wie ein Siegel für einen besonders guten Wein inzwischen.
Also wir haben so eine Brigottesituation momentan, dass einerseits wir diese Trainer auf ein unheimliches Podest heben, dass so ein Trainerwechsel unheimlich energiefreisetzt, auch im Umfeld.
Es werden ganze Bücher nur über Trainer geschrieben.
Nur ganze Bücher nur über Trainer geschrieben. Ja, dass wir da halt tatsächlich sehr viel auf diese Trainer und diese Trainer auch hinein interpretieren, was vielleicht nicht da ist. Auf der anderen Seite haben wir die Situation, dass der Trainer auch der Erste ist, der dann wieder fliegt. Also das steht dann irgendwie einerseits widersportlich, der andereseits passt das auch ganz gut, weil halt immer für diesen Trainer sehr hohe Erwartungen erfolgen. Dieser Trainer ist aber eigentlich in der Verwertungskette im Verein meistens an einer ganz niedrigen Stelle. Dann ist er sehr abhängig von dem, was über ihm passiert. Das sind so zwei interessante Entwicklungen, die miteinander funktionieren.
Ja, interessant. Und es macht auch unglaublich Spaß, sich durch die Fußballlehrer-Jahrgänge zu klicken. Ich habe es für die letzten 30 Jahre vor dieser Sendung gemacht. Es sind echt ein paar interessante Namen mit dabei, mit denen man einfach nicht rechnet. Michael Reschke hat zum Beispiel 1986 den Fußballlehrer gemacht, Andreas Rettig 1990, Klaus Allaus hat ihn gemacht, Frank Wormuth, das ist ja klar, Jörg Schmatke. Interessant fand ich Roman Grill, der 2002 der Berater von Philipp Lahm, den Fußballlehrer mitgemacht hat. Dann später noch mal 2013 beim FC Eastmaning. Ich habe mich in der Recherche verloren an dieser Stelle. Es waren zu viele Namen, die man dann nochmal, ach was macht der eigentlich jetzt, ach könnte ich den mal anfragen und so weiter und so fort. Aber sehr interessant. Michael Rummenigges, Sven Mislintat. Also interessante Namen und auch immer wieder ganz tolle Konstellationen. Björn, wie ist denn der Zusammenhalt zwischen den Trainerinnen? Wenn ich mir zum Beispiel so einen Jahrgang angucke wie 2005, da waren Robin Dutt, Ralf Hasenhüttl, Heiko Herrlich, Bernd Hollerbach, Peter Heubaler, Jürgen Klopp und Andreas Möller. Da hätte ich so ein Mäuschen gespielt bei jeder Gruppenlehr-Einheit.
Ja, natürlich sind es 24 ganz unterschiedliche Charaktere. Es ist so ein bisschen geprägt von Alphatierdasein auch, weil es sind ja auch Persönlichkeiten, die dem Cheftrainer da sein irgendwie frönen oder auch das machen wollen.
Da habe ich auch einen Lieblingsjahrgang, den zitiere ich gleich.
Okay, starke Persönlichkeiten drin. Aber man sitzt dort so was von in einem Boot, es ist ein Riesen-Workflow, weil du musst es so vorstellen, die meisten Trainer haben ja nebenher eine Mannschaft. Die sagen ja nicht, ich mache jetzt zehn Monate keine Mannschaft, sondern die haben von Montags bis Mittwochs diesen Stress dort vor Ort zu sein. Ab Donnerstag gehen die zu ihrer Mannschaft, haben noch zwei Einheiten, machen Abschlusstraining und Donnerstag so ein bisschen. Brauchen einen Super-Co-Trainer zu Hause, haben dann am Wochenende das Spiel, müssen irgendwie Familie händeln, müssen richtig krass viel lernen zwischendurch. Es gibt nicht nur Abschlussprüfungen, sondern immer auch Modul-Tests zwischendurch. Du musst eine Unmenge von Aufgaben erledigen, selber dich vor der Truppe immer präsentieren. Du wirst ständig analysiert, du wirst ständig gespiegelt. Das, was du vorher mal sagtest, mit dem heißen Stuhl, du siehst dich selber ständig vor der Kamera. Das sind sehr außergewöhnliche zehn Monate. Du wirst einmal so komplett aus dem Leben geschossen und dann irgendwie wieder zurückgelassen, zurückgelassen ins Leben. Das ist schon sehr außergewöhnlich, kann ich nur sagen. Und der Zusammenhalt ist aber einfach auch fantastisch. Nicht selten finden sich dort eben auch Konstellationen, wo der Trainer mit dem Co-Trainer dort für ewig dann eben zusammen bleibt oder Leute, die Chef-Trainer werden sich an wen erinnern, der im Lehrgang war und der dann Co-Trainer wird. Also interessant, sehr interessant. Und natürlich, klar, alle dort haben viele Geschichten zu erzählen und man sitzt auch nicht selten abends bei einem Bierchen zusammen. Auch da ist natürlich die Runde auch gemütlich, also dafür bleibt auch genügend Zeit und natürlich ist es fantastisch, dort abends zu sitzen und auch Anekdoten und lustige Geschichten zu hören, die man wirklich auch dann vielleicht off the record lässt.
Ja, da will ich dich jetzt auch nicht zu zwingen, aber unter dem Aspekt habe ich auch einen Lieblingsjahrgang ganz persönlich rausgepackt, 2011, 2012 waren Stefan Effenberg, Jörg Heinrich, Mehmet Scholl, Christian Wörns, Hannes Wolf und Alexander Zorniger unter anderem Teil des Jahrgangs. Das sind so verschiedene Persönlichkeiten, mit so verschiedenen Biografien stelle ich mir unglaublich spannend vor.
Stefan Effenberg und Mehmet Scholl saßen aus Dozentensicht rechts hinten nebeneinander. Was willst du mir erzählen? Hast du schon mal Champions League gespielt?
Ja, finde ich insofern auch deswegen interessant. Ich habe das jetzt quasi nicht nur als Anekdote reingeschmissen, weil Mehmet Scholl der bekannteste Kritiker der DFB-Fußballlehrerausbildung ist. Und der hat eben unter anderem in einem dieser Zitate, die es dann dazu gibt, seinen Mitschüler – oder ja, weiß nicht, ob Schüler jetzt das richtige Wort ist – Hannes Wolf genannt. Ich zitiere mal, was er gesagt hat. Die Tedescos, die Wolves, sie sprießen aus dem Boden und der deutsche Fußball wird sein blaues Wunder erleben. Wir verlieren die Basis, die Kinder müssen abspielen, sie dürfen nicht mehr im Dribbeln ausprobieren, sie bekommen auch nicht mehr die richtigen Hinweise, warum ein Pass oder ein Dribbling nicht gelingt. Und jetzt kommt ein klassischer Mehmet-Scholl-Satz. Stattdessen können sie 18 Systeme rückwärts laufen und furzen. Wie begegnest du solcher Kritik? Du hast ja einige Punkte davon selber vorhin auch schon genannt.
Was sicherlich nicht so gut war, ist, dass er da das mit Namen auch unterlegt hat. Also persönlich Leute immer angesprochen hat. Das war sicherlich nicht so gut. Der Mehmet-Scholl, der war das ein oder andere Mal auch im Lehrgang als externer Referent. Also wir holen auch mal Leute rein, die einen externen Input geben können. Und das ist immer sehr interessant, was der Mehmet-Scholl sagt. Der hat seinen eigenen Kopf, der hat seine eigene Meinung und was er und das hat er auch schon mal im Lehrgang dargestellt. Was für ihn missverständlich rüber kam mit Laptoptrainer, meinte er jetzt nicht, dass jeder da mit einem Laptop nur durch die Gegend läuft. Er hat übrigens wahrscheinlich auch selbst einen Laptop. Er meinte, dass ihm fehlt so ein bisschen die Erfahrung. Spieler, die das selbst mal erlebt haben, dass die ein Stück weit auf der Strecke bleiben. Wo sind denn die Alt-Internationalen? Von denen macht ja auch keiner mehr. Torsten Frings ist jetzt noch mal der Letzte, der richtig viele Länderspiele hatte und den Fußballlehrer gemacht hat. Da kommen ja nicht mehr viele, die das machen. Das war so ein Stück weit das, was er meinte. Und er meinte jetzt weniger, dass die Jungs nur am Laptop sitzen, sondern er meinte, dass sie ständig nur in diesen Systemen denken, ständig nur in Formationen denken und der Mensch dabei ein Stück weit auf der Strecke bleibt. Er spricht immer so von Spielertypen, die du unterschiedlich händeln musst. Aber das machen, das machen die auch alle. Also, dass er als Spieler ein Freigeist war, sagt er immer. Und er musste anders gehandelt werden als jetzt, weiß ich nicht, ein anderer Spieler an seiner Seite. Ich glaube, das war so sein Punkt, den er damit meinte, aber hat das irgendwie nie so richtig dann nochmal richtig und klargestellt.
Aber grundsätzlich ist es ja schon interessant, dass, dass wir da eine, nennen wir es jetzt einfach mal Fehlentwicklung, egal wie dramatisch oder undramatisch das tatsächlich ist, dass es weniger Eins-gegen-eins-Situationen gibt im deutschen Fußball. Wie kann man denn in Zukunft vielleicht verhindern, dass man durch eine eigene Schwerpunktsetzung einen Bereich so offen lässt? Wir hatten das ja auch schon mit anderen Themen. Also wir hatten auch schon mal, die Mittelstürmer-Debatte würde ich immer noch als nicht abgeschlossen bewerten. Also Deutschland hat immer sehr, sehr gute Torhüter, aber beim Mittelstürmer weiß man im deutschen Fußball eigentlich nicht so wirklich, was man da jetzt gerne hätte. Außenverteidiger waren auch ganz häufigen Thema. Es gab mal eine Zeit, in der Sechser ganz, ganz gefragt waren im deutschen Fußball. Lässt sich das denn irgendwie verhindern, dass man nie alles hat in seiner Ausbildung, sondern durch die eigene Schwerpunktsetzung auch Dinge fast ausschließt oder so ein bisschen links liegen lässt?
Also ich glaube, was nach der Ausbildung, was ich hoffe, was wir gehofft haben, dass die Trainer auch mitbekommen, dass es damit bei weitem nicht abgeschlossen ist. Also ich habe einen Fußballlehrer und habe die Weisheit mit Löffeln gefressen. So ist es ja nicht. Sondern dass du selber auch immer wachsam bist für Entwicklungen. Und ich glaube, die richtig guten Trainer, die offen sind für vieles, also Thomas Tuchel ist dafür bekannt, dass er auch über den Tellerrand schaut, auch der Julian, die treffen sich mit Trainern aus anderen Sportarten. Basketball, Hockey, um einfach anderen Input zu bekommen. Beobachten ganz aufmerksam nicht nur den Deutschen, sondern auch den internationalen Fußball. Tauschen sich aus mit anderen Trainern. Das ist etwas, was wir versuchen zu vermitteln. Du musst selber offen bleiben und dann für dich weiter an deiner Philosophie arbeiten und auch dir nicht zu schade sein, das vielleicht mal anzupassen, zu ändern, über den Haufen zu schmeißen und neu entwickeln. Das jetzt an der obersten Spitze. Schwerpunkte musst du halt setzen im unteren Bereich, wo die Trainer wieder in die Vereine gehen und wenn da irgendwas fehlt. Wenn wir von Basics sprechen, der erste Ballkontakt, das Aufdrehen, direkt offensiv zu stehen, technische Dinge. Wenn man merkt, dass sie da verloren gehen, dann muss man da Schwerpunkte setzen, ohne andere zu vernachlässigen. Aber je tiefer ich gehe in der Leistungsklasse, desto weniger Zeit habe ich ja auch für Training. Wenn ich dann nur zweimal die Woche trainiere oder dreimal, habe ich anderen, habe ich ja ganz viel weniger Möglichkeiten, als wenn ich als Profitrainer einen Tag frei habe und sonst jeden Tag auf dem Platz stehe. Das ist ja auch ein Unterschied.
Tobi, wie siehst du denn das, was Mehmet Scholl da gesagt hat und die Entwicklung im deutschen Fußball eben generell?
Das von Mehmet Scholl fand ich sehr populistisch und da bin ich kein riesiger Fan von Populismus. Ich glaube nicht mehr, dass diese Idee, dass jemand ein Laptop-Trainer ist, nur weil er keine Vergangenheit als Profi hat, das sehe ich nicht so.
Das sagst du doch nur, weil du die Domain Laptoptrainer.de hast.
Ja, weil ich dir Laptoptrainer.de gehöre. Ein sehr schlauer Move übrigens. Nein, deswegen gar nicht so sehr, sondern weil das halt so ein Schubladendenken ist. Nicht jeder Ex-Profi ist halt ein Praktiker. Also das gibt es auch unter Ex-Profis. Es gibt auch Theoretiker, die eher theoretisch denken. Es gab vor einigen Wochen auch diese Aussagen von Mario Götze zum Beispiel, der gesagt hat, Pep Guardiola denke ihm zu sehr an Schubladen und zu wenig an Menschen. Was ja dann wieder dann eigentlich nicht passt, weil Guardiola hat auf dem allerhöchsten Niveau Fußball gespielt. Ich würde sogar sagen, fast schon höher als man mit Scholl. Ich finde die Generalisierung immer schwierig und ich finde es auch immer so schwierig, wenn Leute von außerhalb kommen und dann meines besser zu wissen. Das ist natürlich seltsam gesagt, wenn es von mir kommt, weil ich genau das mache. Ich komme von außen meines besser zu wissen.
Und Mehmet Scholl kommt ja von innen zum Beispiel.
Ja, aber Mehmet Scholl kommt auch nicht ganz von innen. Mehmet Scholl ist jetzt auch nicht so, dass er in den letzten Jahren allzu viel als Trainer gearbeitet hat. Er war Experte bei der Sportschau, der hat eigentlich eher meinen Job gemacht, als das, was er kritisiert, quasi in der Trainerausbildung.
Ja, okay, das ist sicher ein richtiger Punkt. Es gab ja auch mal diesen Sonderlehrgang für Nationalspieler, Björn. Im Jahr 2000 war das, da hat man – ja, ich überspitze jetzt – den Fußballlehrer ein paar verdienten Nationalspieler hinterhergeworfen, also von Andreas Brehme, Guido Buchwald über Bernd Hölzenbein, Jürgen Klinsmann hat da seinen Fußballlehrer gemacht, Pierre Litbarski, Joachim Löw übrigens auch, ganz interessant. Stefan Reuter, Matthias Sammer auch, war da mit dabei. Das wurde sehr kritisiert im Nachhinein. Würdest du ausschließen, dass es so etwas in Zukunft noch mal gibt?
Also in so einer abgespeckten Form würde ich das ausschließen.
Das ging über fünf Monate damals.
Ja, das würde ich ausschließen. Was es jetzt noch mal gab, war ein Lehrgang von ehemaligen Profis und Nationalspielern, die haben in einem Sonderlehrgang die A-Lizenz gemacht. Patrick Omoljela, Sebastian Kehl, Miru Klose war auch dabei. Aber nicht in einer besonders abgespeckten Form, einfach in einer Gruppe unter sich. Der Hintergrund war, dass sie sich dort einfach mehr öffnen, mehr von ihrem Input, von ihrer Erfahrung preisgeben. Dass es mal einen Sonderlehrgang gibt, will ich gar nicht ausschließen, Fußballlehrer, aber der würde sicherlich auch einen gewissen Umfang haben und nicht einfach so dahergeschenkt sein. Das schließe ich, glaube ich, aus.
Ich finde diesen Punkt ganz interessant, dass unter anderem der Trainer mehr mit Scholl ist, er ist nicht der Einzige. Aber dass häufiger kritisiert wird, es gäbe heutzutage viele Trainer, denen die Erfahrung als Spieler fair, die ja unbenommen Wert hat, hast du ja vorhin auch schon angesprochen. Kann das vielleicht sein, Björn, dass das so eine Zwischenphase ist? In meinem Gefühl nach hat sich der Fußball in den letzten zehn Jahren so krass verwissenschaftlich und verändert und der Job eines Trainers so sehr verändert, dass es eine Reihe von ehemaligen Spielern gibt, die vielleicht mit dieser Veränderung nicht klarkommen oder sie vielleicht auch nicht mitgehen möchten. Aber es reift jetzt gerade eine neue Generation an zukünftigen Ex-Spielern an, die das sehr wohlmachen. Und dann hast du eben vielleicht einen Christian Kehl, ein Nuri Sahin, sagt schon, dass er sich vielleicht mal im Trainerjob sieht. Miroslav Klose hat jetzt schon ganz viele Stationen genommen, wird jetzt auch beim FC Bayern dann im Nachwuchsbereich tätig sein. Also ist das vielleicht so eine Zwischenphase, dass wir diese Quereinsteiger haben und es wird eine ganz natürliche Entwicklung sein, dass wir wieder mehr Trainer mit Spieler Erfahrungen haben im obersten Bereich?
Das kann durchaus sein. Diese Spieler haben auf jeden Fall auf ihrem Weg jetzt viel Input mitbekommen durch die Trainer, die sie jetzt eben auch erfahren haben. Also wenn du Spieler-Interviews hörst, da wird schon teilweise taktisch auch gesprochen und nicht nur oberflächlich. Die Spieler haben ein großes taktisches Verständnis. Das ist die eine Seite der Medaille. Aber dann ein guter Spieler gewesen zu sein und ein guter Trainer mit allen Facetten, die dazugehören, also auch ein guter Lehrer dann zu sein, also den Fußball dann auch, den ich selber erfahren habe, vermitteln zu können. Du brauchst ja nicht nur Fachkompetenz. Du brauchst ja Führungskompetenz. Du musst führen können. Du brauchst eine Vermittlungskompetenz. Das Wissen, was du im Kopf hast, das ist ja die große Kunst, die Pep Guardiola hat. Er hat eine Vorstellung davon, wie er Fußball spielen möchte und schafft es, dass seine Mannschaften so Fußball spielen, wie er sich das vorstellt. Du brauchst eine Medienkompetenz. Du brauchst eine Sprachkompetenz. Das, was du vermitteln willst, musst du sprachlich rüberbringen. Da gehört viel dazu. Und da ist vielleicht nicht jeder geschaffen, das auch zu machen. Aber der Grundstein wäre gelegt, wenn mehrere das machen. Ein anderer Punkt, warum sie es vielleicht auch nicht machen, ist, finanziell sind sie nicht mehr darauf angewiesen. Trainer oder ehemalige Spieler früherer Generationen waren vielleicht noch nicht durch nach ihrer Karriere, sage ich mal, finanziell. Die Spitzenspieler von heute, davon darf man sich jetzt auch nicht denken. Jeder Bundesligaspieler ist irgendwie durch. Da gibt es eine hohe Quote von Spielern, die aufhören mit der Karriere und auf jeden Fall noch arbeiten müssen irgendwie. Aber die Spitze muss vielleicht nicht mehr unbedingt. Und ob sie danach Lust drauf haben, ja, auch interessanter Punkt. Ob das nun so ist, warum machen sie es denn nicht?
Tobi, du hast dich ja jetzt in deinem Buch, Zeit der Strategen, mit einer ganzen Reihe von Trainern auseinandergesetzt, die den Fußball neu denken. Da zitiere ich jetzt quasi aus dem Untertitel deines Buches. Deswegen ist das ein sehr selbstbewusstes Zitat. Was denken denn diese Trainer neu? Kann man das überhaupt zusammenfassen in einigen Punkten?
Zusammenfassen fällt, glaube ich, schwer, weil sie jeder etwas sehr Eigenes haben, eine sehr eigene Biografie, die ich auch versuche, in dem Buch zu beschreiben. Diese Biografie hat auch sehr stark wieder auf den Menschen einwirkt, wo wir wieder bei diesem Punkt sind. Was sie alle einten natürlich, dass sie diesen Wandel, den der Fußball, den du gerade sehr gut beschrieben hast, den der Fußball gerade mit durchmacht, dass sie den gestalten, dass sie da nicht vorstehen und sich treiben lassen, sondern dass sie versuchen, damit zu gestalten. Sei es in dem sie, wie zum Beispiel Jürgen Klopp, eine sehr genaue Vorstellung davon haben, wie ein Trainerteam zu funktionieren hat. Also wer welche Aufgaben zu übernehmen hat und das Klopp selber gar nicht omnipräsent und alle Aufgaben übernimmt, sondern dass er da sehr viel auch delegiert, dass er da sehr genau arbeitet. Oder halt im anderen Bereich, im praktischen Bereich, das sind Julian Nagelsmann oder Thomas Tuchel, da immer flexibler denken, immer weniger in Schubladen denken, auch immer weniger in diesen Formationen denken. Das sind halt immer so Einzelheiten. Und das finde ich sehr interessant. Ich glaube nicht, dass es so eine Rationalisierung ist von Ergebnissen, aber ich glaube schon, dass die Trainer, die ganz große Ergebnisse haben, auch alle eine sehr eigene Persönlichkeit haben. Also, dass die keine Trainer von der Stange sind, sondern dass du da halt wirklich erkennst, okay, die haben einen sehr interessanten Lebensweg auch und haben auch sehr viel erlebt und haben auch eine sehr interessante Denkeweise. Ich glaube, das unterscheidet noch den Guten von einem sehr guten Trainer.
Gibt es da einen Trainer, du hast dich ja sehr intensiv in ihre Biografien und Spielphilosophien eingearbeitet, der dich nachhaltig beeindruckt hat? Von den elf sind es ja, die du näher vorstellst in deinem Buch.
Eigentlich haben mich alle beeindruckt von den elf Trainern. Und da kommen noch viel mehr hinzu, die ich leider in dem Buch nicht porträtieren konnte. Natürlich sehr beeindruckend fand ich Sinnedinz Zidane tatsächlich, weil er auch in dem, was ich in dem Buch schreibe, sind halt auch sehr viele Taktiker drin und nicht nur Taktiker, aber auch sehr viele Trainer, die sehr intensiv sich Gedanken über alles machen, die sehr intensiv auch arbeiten. Und dann hast du auf einmal einen Ex-Spieler wie Sinnedinz Zidane, der wahrscheinlich sehr vieles von dem, was Scholl gesagt hat, unterschreiben würde, der natürlich auch sehr intensiv arbeitet. Gar keine Frage, aber der auch Sätze sagt, wie Spielern, während einer Sitzung mehr als einen taktischen Punkt an die Hand zu geben, ist Quatsch. Das vergesst du eh. Ich gebe dir nur einen taktischen Punkt pro Sitzung an die Hand. Was ja im Widerspruch steht, zu viel muss andere Trainer machen. Zum Beispiel Julian Nagelsmann, der sagt, ich mache lieber vier Punkte. Und die merken sich dann zwei, als dass ich nur einen Punkt mache. Das fand ich sehr, sehr interessant auch, dass dieser Weg trotzdem noch funktioniert. Und zwar trotzdem noch funktioniert, aber dass der auch heute noch funktioniert. Und dass der halt, wenn du ihn richtig vorgetragen bekommst, was er mit seiner Ruhe und seiner Ausstrahlung machen kann, dass das dann noch funktioniert.
Ja, das fand ich auch sehr interessant. Und ich finde es auch schön, dass man allein anhand der Auswahl der Trainer in deinem Buch erkennt, es ist keine Frage des Alters. Es kann also, ob man Fußball neu denkt, in Anführungszeichen, und da den Fußball weiterentwickelt. Da haben wir alte Haudegen mit dabei. Mir ist das Kapitel zu Maurizio Sarri im Gedächtnis geblieben, einfach weil ich da viele Dinge noch nicht wusste über seinen Lebensweg. Dass er sich im Grunde hochgecoacht hat von der fast niedrigsten italienischen Liga bis in die Serie A bis jetzt zum SSC in Neapel. Unglaubliche Geschichte, unglaublicher Typ. Auch mit einigen Dingen, die ich dann gar nicht so toll finde. Einige Sachen sagt er.
Ja, aber das finde ich gar nicht so schlimm teilweise. Der ist halt ungeschliffen. Also der ist auch gerne mal homophob unterwegs. Der raucht wie ein Schlot. Der kommt halt nicht aus dieser Trainer-Gilde. Der kommt halt nicht aus der Fußballwelt. Das finde ich das Spannende an Sarri.
Genau, wirkt wie so ein Antikörper. Genau diese homophoben Äußerungen sind das, was mich. Ja klar, mich stört es auch. Ich will das nicht gar nicht gutheißen, also um Gottes Willen. Aber das finde ich halt einen interessanten Punkt, den man vielleicht hier verknüpfen könnte mit dieser Debatte über die Ausbildung. Da ist natürlich so ein Typ wie Sarri, der ein Banker ist, der in seiner Freizeit Trainer macht, der dann irgendwann den Trainer an den Nagel hängt, dass diese Biografien natürlich sehr schwer sind.
Den Banker an den Nagel hängt, nicht den Trainer.
Den Banker an den Nagel hängt, sorry. Den Banker an den Nagel hängt. Das sind Biografien, die mit der aktuellen Form, wie die Trainerausbildung in Deutschland läuft, schwierig möglich sind, sage ich mal so. Weil die Trainerausbildung in Deutschland verlangt relativ früh von dir, dass du da zumindest einige Pferde draufsetzt. Also du kommst nicht mehr oben hin als Quereinsteiger, sondern du musst dich da hocharbeiten. Was viele, viele Vorteile hat, aber wodurch natürlich auch manches vielleicht verloren geht. Also manche Facetten gehen dadurch vielleicht verloren. So blöd es klingt.
Würdest du dem zustimmen, Björn?
Was meinst du mit Quereinsteiger? Dass du relativ spät auf die Karte Fußballtrainer setzt.
Genau. Also bei Sarri um die Biografie da vielleicht, die ist da nicht eingeräufig, der hat ja tatsächlich angefangen in der untersten italienischen Liga und hat dann sich nach und nach, er hat in jeder italienischen Liga gecoacht. Also von der untersten bis zur obersten. Weil er sich halt wirklich nach und nach hochgearbeitet hat und hat bis, ich glaube 2001 oder 2002 noch in der Bank gearbeitet. Als Banker so. Und der ist dann einfach als Typ auch ganz anders. Das gibt es natürlich heute auch noch, klar, sage ich gar nichts dagegen. Das gibt es auch im deutschen Fußball noch. Aber da ist dieser Prozess natürlich auch schwieriger. Da hast du natürlich sehr viele, ich sag mal, böse gemeint Karriere.
Ja, ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob das mit der Struktur der Trainerausbildung zu tun hat, weil das ist ja schon auch für andere Länder eher ein Alleinstellungsmerkmal. Dass jemand sich so von ganz unten hoch arbeitet. Also weiß ich nicht, ob das mit der Struktur der Ausbildung zu tun hat. Aber sicherlich ist es eher eine einzigartige Story. Und in Deutschland gibt es – ja, die Ausbildung steht für hohe Qualität. Also das weiß ich auch von anderen Ländern, dass die deutsche Ausbildung da hoch angesehen wird. Und da gehst du natürlich eher so strikt deinen Weg. Das stimmt. Das ist ein bisschen vorgegeben. Der Karriereweg ist nicht vorgegeben, aber der Ausbildungsweg ist so vorgegeben. Du kannst halt nicht unten trainieren. Oder du kannst halt nur gewisse Liga trainieren, wenn du auch die Lizenz dazu hast.
Und du musst dann auch immer in den Schritten denken. Richtig. Okay, wenn ich da weitermachen will, muss ich auf dem und dem Niveau so und so lange trainiert haben. Ich finde das richtig. Ich finde das auch wichtig, weil du da halt eine Qualität reinbringst. Aber es ist natürlich auch die Quartatur des Kreises, was ich hier gerade verlange. Du kannst halt nicht eine bestimmte Qualität reinbringen wollen und dann sagen, okay, aber wir nehmen jetzt den Kreisklasse-Trainer mit in die Fußballlehrer-Ausbildung. Das geht natürlich nicht. Aber es ist natürlich, du entscheidest dich für einen bestimmten Weg. Und dann hast du dieser bestimmte Weg auch immer Nachteile.
Dadurch wird der Beruf des Fußballtrainers aber auch ein Stück weit zu einem Ausbildungsberuf. Also du gehst da wirklich, das ist ja mittlerweile, ich finde zum Glück so, dass es nicht heißt, ich habe 250 Bundesligaspiele und werde automatisch Bundesligatrainer, wie es ja vor zig Jahren war. Das war ja ein Inner Circle. Da waren ja immer wieder dieselben Namen auf dem Karussell. Immer wieder dieselben Namen. Und die Fluktuation ist ja da jetzt höher. Und man muss sich nur anschauen, welche Trainer gerade auf dem Markt sind, die gerade keinen Verein haben. Da sind schon qualitativ hochwertige Namen dabei. Und da weißt du eigentlich, selbst wenn du gute Arbeit gemacht hast, mal gar nicht, komme ich da wieder rein in diesen Zirke. Aber durch die Struktur der Ausbildung ist es ein richtiger Ausbildungsberuf geworden. Du musst Lehrgänge machen, du musst arbeiten, du hast Lehrjahre, du bist in unteren Ligen, wo du noch Fehler machen kannst, bis du irgendwann mal vielleicht die Chance hast, oben anzukommen.
Das ist wieder dann die andere Seite der Medaille, die ich auch immer so ein bisschen beschreibe, dass du mittlerweile Karriere als Fußballtrainer machen kannst. Was ja dann auch wieder eine positive Sache ist. Also ein Julian Nagelsmann, den glaube ich, keiner die fachliche Qualität absprechen würde, der hat der sich ganz bewusst irgendwann an einem sehr frühen Punkt seines Lebens dafür entschieden, dass er Fußballtrainer wird. Dass er halt das BWL-Studium schmeißt und dass er sagt, ich werde Fußballtrainer. Und das funktioniert natürlich mit dieser Form der Ausbildung sehr gut.
Abschließende Frage an euch zwei. Björn, du darfst beginnen. Hast du einen Lieblingstrainer? Und wenn ja, warum? Oder eine Trainerin? Können Sie wegen mir auch gerne.
Ich bin so ein bisschen, also Jürgen Klopp finde ich klasse. Ich finde Jürgen Klopp klasse, einerseits, weil ich ihn acht Wochen hautnah erlebt habe und sagen kann, dass er so authentisch wie er rüberkommt im Fernsehen, der ist eins zu eins so, wenn du ihm gegenüber sitzt. Sein Umgang oder seine Persönlichkeit ist einfach faszinierend. Das ist ein Stück weit auch was du vielleicht gar nicht lernen kannst. Seine Fähigkeit, jeden mit ins Boot zu holen, seine Fähigkeit, dir von der ersten Sekunde quasi das Gefühl zu geben, du bist vollwertiges Mitglied dieser Gemeinschaft. Das fand ich fantastisch, seine Art Mannschaften zu führen, seine Emotionalität und den Fußball finde ich natürlich auch interessant, den er spielen lässt. Jürgen Klopp finde ich immer wieder gerne, höre ich mir auch PKs von ihm an. Sehr schlagfertig, also schon ein klasse Typ.
Ja, da bist du nicht ganz alleine. Tobi, hast du einen Lieblingstrainer? Wir wissen ja von dir, dass du keinen Lieblingsverein hast. Gibt es denn einen Trainer?
Ich überlege jetzt schon die ganze Zeit. Ich werde wahrscheinlich jetzt sagen, wenn du jetzt aktuelle Trainer meinst, dann würde ich sagen Joachim Löw. Was erstmal eine seltsame Wahl klingt, aber er ist einfach so ein Trainer, den ich jetzt schon seit zehn Jahren begleite, also mit dem ich auch quasi in diesen Fußball sozialisiert wurde.
Jetzt bin ich gespannt, wie die Situation von Joachim Löw ist, wenn das hier veröffentlicht wird. Liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, wir nehmen am Tag vor der WM 2018 auf. Also sollte es in der Vorrunde vorbei gewesen sein.
Da habe ich jetzt gar nicht dran gedacht. Aber ich bleibe bei Joachim Löw, weil ich auch interessant finde, wie er sich entwickelt hat. Also dass er sich immer weiterentwickelt, immer Neues entdeckt, immer wieder neue Wege geht, nicht stehen bleibt, nicht sich auf seinen eigenen Erfolgen ausruht und weil er auch ruhig geworden ist mit dem Jahr. Also das hoffe ich mir für mich selber auch, dass ich mit der Zeit ruhiger werde, wie er es geworden ist.
Du bist ja auch so als aufbrausender Hansdampf in allen Gassen bekannt.
Ja, nee, aber privat so noch. Ich nehme ja schon Sachen so persönlich, wo er die, glaube ich, nicht mehr persönlich nimmt. Die er, glaube ich, vor zehn Jahren auch persönlich genommen hat, die er heute nicht mehr persönlich nimmt. Und ansonsten Sepp Herberger natürlich, der einfach als Figur im deutschen Fußball einmalig ist. Also auch nicht den rundesten Lebenslauf hat, auch da viele Ecken dabei, gerade in der Nazizeit. Aber der halt für den Fußball in Deutschland sehr viel getan hat und der auch sehr, der mit seinen Sätzen, mit seiner Art, den deutschen Fußball nachhaltig geprägt hat. Und das finde ich immer eine sehr interessante Figur, weil er auch dieses Theoretische sehr gut immer verknüpft hat mit den Praktischen. Also er ist da immer den Mittelweg gegangen.
Das finde ich jetzt richtig klasse. Wir haben diese Folge begonnen mit Domenico Tedesco, der über Julian Nagelsmann spricht. Und wir enden mit Sepp Herberger. Und ich finde, einen schöneren Schluss kann es für so eine Folge nicht geben, egal wie lange ich noch mit euch hätte sprechen können. Ich habe eure Zeit schon überüber strapaziert. Deswegen ganz, ganz, ganz herzlichen Dank. Zum einen an Björn Müller. Björn, vielen, vielen Dank, dass du dir Zeit genommen hast. Ich hoffe, dass wir uns nochmal wiederhören im Rasenfunk. Denn mir hat es großen Spaß beratet, dir zuzuhören.
Ich danke für die Einladung und hoffe auch, dass wir das vielleicht irgendwie an einer anderen Stelle wiederholen.
Komme ich sehr gerne drauf zurück. Und außerdem herzlichen Dank an Tobias Escher. Kauf das Buch Die Zeit der Strategen, Vigard Jola, Löw, Mourinho und Co. den Fußball Neudenken. Es ist erschienen bei Rowohlt und wie alles, was Tobi anfasst, sehr empfehlenswert. Danke dir, lieber Tobi. Immer wieder gerne. Und dann auch euch lieben Dank, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, fürs Zuhören, fürs Interesse an diesem Tribünengespräch. Wir freuen uns über Feedback auf allen Social-Media-Plattformen im Forum. Wir freuen uns, wenn ihr auch andere Tribünengespräche hört. Vielleicht mal in die Schlusskonferenzen reinhört. Und dann, ja, sind wir gespannt aufs Feedback. Eine gute Zeit euch allen und bis zum nächsten Mal im Rasenfunk. Egal, ob im Tribünengespräch, Schlusskonferenz oder Kurzpass.
Das war das Rasenfunk – Tribünengespräch.
Wir gehen nun zurück um die angeschlossenen Funkhäuser.